day seven of clutch chest champions
showdown
the two best chess players in the world
entered the ring
for a heavyweight battle at the highest
level world champion magnus carlson
played masterfully
to take the lead twice but fabiano
caruana bounced back each time
to tie up the match going into the final
day there are six games remaining for a
champion to be crowned
the epic finale of clutch chess coming
up next
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of
clutch chess i'm jennifer shahady and i
am here with maurice ashley
and yasser sarawan for an epic finale
featuring
the top two players in the world hey yes
hello jennifer hello maurice hello
everyone
and welcome to the final day of the
final match
of this clutch chess event i tell you
it's been a scriptwriter's dream
number one and number two players
trading heavy blows with one another's
we saw
peaks of brilliance and well
valleys of anguish let's put it like
that but it's been fantastic
uh i hate the fact that it's coming to
an end but all good things must come to
an end
maurice how do you see it yourself
well you want the end to be sweet you
want it to be climactic and we've got
that on our hands the score is
deadlocked at 4-4 where the two best
players
on the planet they're swinging at each
other one hits
the other hits back what more could you
want this is the finale
you dream of when you have a tournament
exactly
and this is what it looked like
yesterday guys we've never had
a day of clutch test that was exactly
like this
and what you see here is that not only
is the score tied up
but they also have the same tie breaks
because they each won
one clutch jazz game so it was all about
magnus hitting
and bobby hitting right back that's
exactly and what is the format
like for today john well we've got six
games left we have got
four games at our regular regular point
system
one point a game and then we have our
three point games
clutch games that's games 11 and 12. and
for those of you who are just joining us
well
boy you missed a lot but it's all
archived on youtube
our time control is game 10 with a five
second increment
now what would happen in case of a
playoff
well if there's a playoff well there
could be a playoff basically because
the clutch points are tied right now so
if
the players do each win one clutch game
and for instance draw the rest of the
games we will go to a blitz match to
determine the winner
and also potential armageddon game oh my
goodness that if it came down to that
that would be really amazing and maurice
in terms of head to head how do the
players match up
well as zeke will imagine these players
have seen each other so often over the
last several years
they've just been at the top of the food
chain in world chess
of course magnus at number one and fabi
at number two right now these results
suggest that for sure 4-4 tie each
winning
2 000 of clutch money in those games
five and six and how dramatic was that
game six
bobby looked dead to all rights he said
if i had lost that game
this would have been over no but he
rided the ship and managed to come back
and as we said they have played each
other
most notably in a world championship
match back in 2018
they battled epically in london that
struggle that we all were
enthralled by we called it and guess
what
12 games 12 draws they could not
land a blow in the classical portion of
the event it took
rapid chess for magnus to show his super
superiority at that stage the [ __ ]
thing look i'm sorry i'm trying to make
a little dent now get a little
reputation
as also clutch at rapids don't think
that you'll always run away with it
magnus might say though listen our
numbers tell the truth
i'm 211 against you yeah they've been
nine draws
but when it comes down to it i have been
dominating you
over the years bobby certainly does not
want that
to remain as the reputation for sure so
he would love it if he could nick magnus
in this event so that everybody
remembers hey what have you done for me
lately
and it's what is the most recent story
that's what people are going to be
quoting will bobby be able to get it
done or will
magnus prove once again that he is the
boss
at any kind of chess a lot of bragging
rights at stake for sure but
uh jen take us to the business end
what's at stake
well 265 000 and that's historic
it's the largest prize fund ever offered
for an
online chess event including 50 000 for
the winner
that's 35 000 for the runner-up so both
players coming home with quite a chunk
of chain
wow and then the clutch money keeps
growing maurice
oh man it's been growing and growing the
clutch game 12s
in the quarterfinals and semi-finals
ended
in draws that is in three of them and
put that together
and you get twenty thousand dollars that
got pushed over
to these here finals and we're going to
see this today instead of being worth
the traditional
3 000 that clutch games 11 and 12s are
normally worth
today they're worth 13 000 each
add that up that's 26 000 the player's
already taken four
of from these finals so that's a thirty
thousand dollar
rollover as you see there to date magnus
has already won
twelve thousand in clutch money fobby
with
eight grand man that could be first
place in a lot of tournaments
that is something special and they got a
long way to go
i think they're thinking more about the
titles but you know along the way
i get the title and i get some money why
not
well the fifty thousand dollars first is
plenty to play for
wow thank you st louis chess club what a
fantastic event and again
thank you all for joining us it's really
great to have you along with us all
and we're i i'm on pins and needles i'm
ready to call the action
i want to get into the games absolutely
yes and indeed welcome to everybody
who's uh jess joining us you can use our
hashtag clutchchest
interact and of course everything
archived on the st
louis chess club channel if you missed
any of the action it's been
pretty hot and heavy yes exactly let's
just take a look at
who we picked oh well look at this
we all are looking decent with our
predictions now i gotta tell you i asked
my
um three-year-old son fabian and he
agreed with you guys
you said yeah and maurice know what's up
here
mommy you're right yeah
you're just smart uh astute child
how gifted at such a young age i mean
exactly wow
you're raising a smart one there and he
even said that bobby was going to win by
a lot
and then he was going to check mate with
a bond so
maybe i i overestimated his iq
well four four for the moment that's a
lot of bragging rights for
all of us and again number one versus
number two i don't care what your sport
is when those when
the top two athletes in any sport
uh get together i mean it's worth
watching and
day one was exceptional i mean there
were some certain moments of day one
which i thought were just in brilliant
just
you know like you would think that they
were playing classical chess
not this rapid form of chess and then
some really
anguishing moments there and you saw it
in your interview with
magnus after the game maurice oh yes
he was so frustrated and he said so he
felt like
he had this and there were some games
game one for example that he was just
completely winning and he let time
pressure
affect him and he has been playing
slowly that has been
his weakness so far in this particular
phase
uh in the finals before we didn't notice
it at all
right that he was having any difficulty
he mentioned that
on the tour he's been slow but so far
against jeffrey against lavonne
we didn't notice any time issues
whatsoever i guess when the pressure is
on and you're facing number two in the
world
you might have to think a little bit
more and he
has done so and because of it he's made
sub optimal moves maybe even egregious
errors
well he's going to have to fix that he's
gonna have to right the ship and we see
there fabi
in place as we await the world champion
to sit in the chair
he's gonna have to fix that that's
that's been fabi's edge playing quickly
we see that it's 10 minutes guys that's
not a lot of time
so it matters how you manage your time
when you play these games
absolutely although if they do both get
down to a similar time usually it goes
in magnus's favor but bobby was
brilliant and staying ahead of the clock
so much
but i gotta say i agree with you yes
there were some stellar moments
one that really popped out for me is um
when fabi allowed work takes g7 check
and at first we were all like what
you know um he's just getting crushed
like how you can't do this and
it actually turned out that he got a ton
of counter play and then it was a
brilliant conception
you're talking about game five in
particular right like yeah that's right
you did end up losing the game in the
end right but not because of that though
yeah but the idea was was just
breathtaking i thought
and how about the king f2 fred attack
by magnus and gabe
magnus just sat down by the way and i
saw him
buttoning the shirt maybe he decided to
switch shirts
at the last minute because he just
sat down and in a bit of a rush
and uh there he's still buttoning the
shirt there he goes the
button's on and we're all off
and we've got my favorite opening the
sicilian is on tap
but um you know we have seen a lot of
knight c6 bishop b5s in this event
and we certainly have and what what
games they've been
i mean really uh back and forth
games and magnus yesterday maurice again
in his interview with you he seemed to
have
a little bit of disdain for fabi he said
he got a winning game in game
six just so easily he couldn't believe
his eyes it was
almost like he he insulted his opponent
he didn't know what he was doing
said you said almost he did he said he
didn't understand the position
at all there you go and that's that's a
straight up and look at this
already bishop d6
that is not your traditional move guys
bishop
d6 after e5 castles blocking the d-pawn
of course you're defending your e-pawn
so bishop takes on c6 is not met by 95
but this is not your traditional move
and magnus expected to gain a little
edge on the clock
because of this and he has already given
fabi some pause as bobby says okay the
guy prepped something for me
right out the gate let me be cool let me
be calm let me just play d3
and keep it going wow i was just i was
trying to refute it with knight f3
knight c4 it's not like you just
refute the opening but bishop d6
man i got to look at that askance and
say seriously well
we've seen some some great experiments
by
magnus he doesn't always get away with
them
but um he has been mixing it up you
gotta
you gotta say that you know i have to
think also though
with the black pieces when you
experiment
white usually can play some kind of
nonsense
and still get equality right so if
you're
white when you're in a classical game
you know how we are
we think i'm going to kill you for
playing a move like that
right as you said you want to refute the
line
but when you're playing ten minute and
it's the somebody especially like the
world champion throws it on you
fabi is being very smart he said you
know what
let me just play quickly play a sensible
move
if we get an equal position so what it
doesn't matter
i don't have to prove anything out of
the opening i've just got to get a
position i can play
and be okay on the clock you could burn
a lot of time
trying to refute this and then you'll
only have three minutes on the clock you
thought oh
i tried to refute it i didn't find
anything and even if i did to find
something decent
it's not killing the guy and you're just
behind on on time
yeah and we remember remember when
hikaro nakamura went through a blitz
stage or a lot of players do this for
fun
where they just play like king f2 f3 on
the first few moves bring their king
back to g1 and
especially in bullet it's pretty
frustrating because if you burn 10
seconds trying to figure out how to make
that
forget it you could actually be you know
losing
more than you gain and speaking of the
uh of hikaru nakamura i can't tell you
but after bishop to d6
the move looks so bizarre people might
think that they were tuning into
pogchamps for a second
you're being unfair to the pawn champs
uh well you're referring to it
we should let the fans know you're
referring to an event that hikaru is
currently
doing commentary for which is what the
conflict he had
and not being able to play in this event
i'm sure he wishes that he could have
had some
some uh chances to to land some blows
in this that was so exciting but it was
a conflict he had
he had to go do his business there
what we have though is some special
chess that has been going on and magnus
has played
the move bishop to e7 and we've seen
some kicks a6
h6 on the board as well and this is
looking a lot more normal if you saw
this position
you wouldn't think that the bishop was
at any point on the d6 square
yeah so wait so let's back up why why
did we go bishop d6 and bishop b7
because
i was like making this joke about the
pog champs and i didn't like what was
the reason for it yes you you must
figure it out
exactly so after the move uh bishop d6
and we had this bishop g5 bishop h4
action
a7 a6 so uh
fabi has gotten a tempo from the world
champion and the russell limo oftentimes
you voluntarily capture
now i think what fabby didn't want to
see
was something like a g5 and a queen e7
and maybe castles long so he decided to
bring his bishop
back to c4 with bishop c4
and then after bishop c4 now
that this knight wasn't going to be
captured
okay magnus just dropped his bishop back
and said no harm
no foul you took a tempo back and forth
and i'll take a tempo back and forth
and after these moves uh help me out
what happened
next after bishop e7 after b7 we saw
c3 castles knight b2 d6
a4 knight h5 bishop g3 g6
so basically what you're saying is is
even though bishop d6 looks like
a move that a professional player
doesn't play because you're moving your
bishop in front of a pawn it actually
had a very specific purpose and
it did seems like black is doing okay
indeed and it
if you had told me that this variation
came out of some kind of a
two nights joko piano with bishop e7
what
we might call the hungarian variation i
said yeah okay
you say it started to as a sicilian i go
what
how did we get here if it was a sicilian
so it does look very transpositional but
the way the players got here is very
different
now this move g7 g6 sets the table
in a completely different type of a way
because what this move says to me is
that black
is ready to move his king and to play
for the move f5
strategically speaking that's a huge
commitment to make
f5 comes with enormous force it would
essentially trap
the bishop so whatever white does and i
think he's going to have to do something
based on the move d3 d4
uh he better do it quickly because king
h7f5 can
happen and we didn't see by the way we
moved rook e1
and and magnus traded immediately on g3
the problem with f5
is that after you prepare it with let's
say with kg7 instead of trading
uh because of that pin the problem is
that
f5 white can actually capture on f5 and
you traditionally want to capture back
with a pawn
however there's a discovery with your
knight knight takes on
e5 that's playable so if we we follow
this
uh well in this particular position it
is tricky because you see this line and
gets very sharp because after it takes
on
e5 then if you take on g3 now because
your knight's hanging
then white has this intermediate move
knight takes c6
hitting your queen and then your knight
on g3 will hang
now it so happens in this position that
after takes knight takes e5 black can
actually
take with the pawn and because after
queen takes h5 you think you've just won
your material back
f4 lands on the board with force your
bishop is actually
trapped in this position so that rook c1
would not
have been the best way to prepare for
this particular tactic maybe h3
which looks a little bizarre to be
honest uh given that knight takes g3
would be possible
but at any rate we're now in this
position and fabi's knight
has dropped back to f1 and it's
certainly headed to
the d5 square while we've been talking
however
magnus has managed to play h5 and h4
talk about your non-traditional attack
he's looking for the h file instead of
the f5
push that we would have expected i mean
magnus is playing surprising move after
surprising move
from the get-go in this game absolutely
definitely mixing it up in all kinds
in all kinds of ways sorry i've got the
wrong yeah and i have to say i'm
impressed with both players in that i
feel like what maurice said earlier at
the beginning of the show
like fabi is not ahead on time but he's
not down on time either
and with the types of moves magnus is
playing um
and the fact that it's that he's out of
book i i feel like that's pretty cool
yeah well no question about it this is a
very different position
than what we would have expected from
the e4 c5
sicilian opening knight f1 h5 i've got
to say
by the way i'm really impressed by this
decision
from magnus i mean if magnus had played
f5 and just gone down a traditional
pathway with f5 and f4 after takes
this rook on e1 would suddenly have a
very meaningful job
along the e file by playing h5 which we
see
knight e3 h4 magnus has basically said
look you know we all know the rook on e1
is a
is what is well placed especially when
the center gets
opened but i am not going to play for
the opening of the center i'm playing
to open up the h file i just put my rook
on h8
and my rook on h8 says magnus to his
opponent
will be a lot more meaningful than your
rook on e1
and we have seen some moves sorry let me
catch up to date with the players g3
bishop g5 okay a little surprise for me
i
would have assumed that the bishop would
have gone home to f6 we saw
knight takes g5 queen takes g5
and fabby already a little bit concerned
maybe
that's concerned as as far as i can tell
because
he's really worried about the attack and
he's not looking for d4
talk about not refuting this opening at
all right
he has played this in in very
restrained fashion as if to say you know
what
i see what you're doing uh i i don't
know that this is good for me you prep
this
let me just get a good position and now
he's taking on n5 let me just get a
decent position let's put it that way he
wants to fight for the h file as well
and magnus is saying no can do now i'll
play for f5
and i'm just going to attack you well
exactly
and magnus is actually taking some
time over this decision of how he wants
to recapture
on f5 kings indian defense players perk
defense players like myself we
automatically reach for the pawn
we'd like to have you the attack f5 f4
the fact that magnus has thought
for well well more than maybe half a
minute
suggest to me that bishop takes f5 as
serious let's give that
the same respect that magnus is giving
it um
bishop takes f5 what's what's white's
most likely course of action well
there's a threat bishop takes d3 as a
concrete threat
and if you take yeah you deal with that
and and
you don't exactly want to take this
bishop but in the king's indian it
often happens in these formations that
once you get rid of this light square
piece
you should be okay the problem i would
think
is that bishop on c4 is sort of out of
play
and an e4 move if he could just get it
going
that knight would show up on e5 and then
get to the f3 square
so here the other rook shows up on the f
file
the other may show up on the h file your
last move by the way i would put the
rook on the h and he's taken with the
bishop
i put the rook on the h file yes that
looks very strong as well i mean
you've got to be mindful this is a real
attack yeah
i had this really great cheapo that i
just wanted to share before i put the
rook on the h-file
let's just go along with play along with
me for a moment because i really like
what you were saying
about that e5 e4 move and you play it
now and it's sort of like
oh if i could get my knight to e5 and
shooting
shoot the gap queen takes and then
suddenly well well that's pretty weird
how often have you seen that a queen on
g5
and a rook on f5 happen to
link together along the fifth rank to
play d5 winning a piece
quite an unusual oops sorry quite an
unusual tactic
going on but bishop takes f5 on the
board uh
bring me up to date is this the currency
i take that five check was just played
work takes f5 immediately immediately
says we're not going to see where
i would not want to leave my king side
alone by playing queen d5
a queen a2 makes sense queen e3 made
sense
and it was here that maybe you're
reckoning on a rook h8 idea because
there is a triple there is a triple
threat you could go
rook to h8 let's just make a move for
white i don't know if this is a good
move or a bad move
but you get what's coming here oh yeah
actually to first the rook might make a
pit stop on h2
to kick your queen out because right
obviously bishop d5 is going to be the
only defense in this position you're
going to put a bishop on this lawn
diagonal
and uh and pray that your bishop cannot
be ejected
but after rook h2 hitting your bishop
your queen
will have to move out of there so for
example
here rook h2 could be dangerous and by
the way the night going to e7
and that bishop is not going to have any
security
whatsoever 97 could be problematic
well not in this position because yeah
we do have actually hung mate in that
position
finally aligned with yeah
that would have been bad news to miss
that one right at 97 here you set up
your own
your own i guess this would be a epilet
style mate
i like how and then of course black is
threatening all sorts of nasty stuff
with
rookie h1 himself it's always fun when
if white to move is made black moves
made
those are the problems that you get a
lot of mileage from well
magnus has doubled on the f file with a
threat and now he's
after rookie two he has planted
his rook on f3 which is which is
actually humorous because obviously
bishop to d5
can be met by rook takes on d3
but then bishop bishop before there's
rook d2
right well you're not trapping the rook
but
isn't the knight on c6 hanging true i
guess
can i leave and go snack i'd be a little
worried
not bishop before he has but but takes
immediately
i would be worried if i were white
because there's rook g3 possible
and if i take on c6 it just looks like
i think maybe something oh man be
careful with your king
your king is slightly exposed as well a
rook could land on g2 so
i don't know he's just doubled rooks
right
let's get to the game because this game
position now
the only thing missing we're getting a
blunder alert
and i was going to say the only thing
missing is
the knight on c6 and e4 has happened
and this is a problem that knight's
going to land on e5
oh that's a great move e4 so
rook ae1 was the blunder um because it
allowed
e4 so what what did we do what were we
supposed to do instead bishop d5
yeah uh we saw this reaction by daddy
too
it was like oh man why did i allow e4
and e4 is huge i mean that just
oh because because the knight is coming
to e5
and then we just then we can just like
move our rook and play knight f3
check oh it's also also another problem
when the knight lands on e5
where do you put your undefended bishop
your bishop is also a problem you can't
move it because knight d3 is monstrous
knight d3 is a killer f2 is hanging e1
is hanging
this is over what about work takes c4
then you just have d5 if
not rook takes f2 huh yep
well e4 is a shot
he didn't realize it was we talked about
this move
the knight wants to be in the game but
he thought he was doubling
matter of fact you know what's what's
crazy the doubling of
rooks actually does nothing that's the
worst part
you're not threatening anything when you
double rooks you're not threatening d4
you're not threatening to move your rook
to e4 your rook
rook e1 is actually a completely
meaningless move
rook f1 would have made more sense
bishop d5 some other move
but rook e1 itself is a meaningless move
and the rook on e2 is actually in the
way because
we would maybe be able to at least
survive a little bit if we could play
bishop e2 here
and then you know queen f2 rook after
you came out right but honestly our work
is in the way of us
even defending that position maybe rook
c2 was a
playable move at any rate by the way
after
e4 which we think is a a
killing shot we just think this is a
great shot by magnus
d takes e4 knight e five bishop
e6 on the board yep so what's the best
way here what about
rook f6 yes what do you think exactly
you start to think
maybe i could just nudge the bishop if
you nudge the bishop
pardon me if you nudge the bishop with
this rook
then i can maybe hide away over here
so but the most direct threat is the
question the bishop is not doing us
any harm on on this square why are we
going after a bishop
when knight d3 we've been talking about
like what's wrong with the landing on d3
absolutely absolutely great because we
don't allow the f4 move right rook f6 f4
we got a little overly excited there we
don't need to do it why don't we just go
take the part is the pawn not hanging
rook g3 is a
monster threat the knight has landed on
d3
and this is killer blow vicious
is resigns this position you you have
you're just losing your queen
magnus that's right i mean it's a great
it's a great move knight d3
knight takes f2 and in the end it's not
that we're breaking through
to it's that we collapse the protection
of g3
yep precisely you know what just
watching the way fabi handled this game
he played it so softly he played he said
you know what let me just trade off and
try to protect
that's the wrong attitude you got the
white pieces the guy plays something
um bold we'll call it
you can't just think i'm just going to
back down and play soft
and magnus came straight out of the gate
right at him
with the black pieces and said i'm just
going to play aggressively he played
with h5
and what's this bishop f5 he was hoping
that this would do something knight
takes on e1 this was an exchange sack we
saw yesterday
do we believe it i don't think so
i don't think so what uh what he's
hoping
is that he's going to get some tricks
against the rook on f3 but knight takes
e1
not just grab the exchange it also
defends the rook you don't have time to
take
that's why we saw rook takes e1 and now
um
to play uh pardon me he could move his
rooks for starters like
what's wrong with just moving the rook
the bishop on this is a moment ago the
rook was gonna
the rook was taking a pawn in a previous
variation now the rook just landed on d3
it's ready to come to d2 this
looks terrible f4 hanging the pawn on g3
oh dear oh yeah that's that's an
exchange
and no pawns and in fact it looks like
white will drop a pawn in the end
because your bishop on f5 is intake and
then f4 hangs
this is hopeful so the most the most
straightforward jen is something like
this
check to the king the king the rook goes
away
this is maybe what fabby has is hoping
for
that he could get some kind of miracle
perpetual
repetition against the right actually
it's this rook g1 move he was counting
on
that he would somehow have value but
bangers
with the rook on f6 king e2c4
on the board defending the rook and rook
g1 followed by rook f6
give me that one move threat that's
taken care of
and that's that you got no more threats
king f7 is coming your f pawn is going
to hang
if he resigns now it would be with good
conscience clear conscience for sure
because there's nothing to do here he
played
the movie rook g4 g4 angling for bishop
c8
while defending the f4 pawn he knows
that your move king f7 is on tap
so that's why uh he he defended the pawn
in anticipation
now well d5 live looks really d5
undermines everything there goes that
strong big time threat to take well
no surprises there magnus did play the
move d5
and fabi's defenses are totally split
apart
yeah he can't he can't hold on to
everything and even if you could hold on
to something you'd probably be losing
anyway
as magnus is just um not only
going to be up in exchange but he's
going to be a pawns too
for not a great start for at all
by the way the move rook b6 could be a
monstrous threat
not okay to me that uh fabby played
a5 just hoping for a mistake by magnus
by the way
uh has magnus made a mistake at all in
this game
um maybe maybe the opening
i mean he's just playing it perfect
right i mean he's got
everything under control this move b6
give me this uh attack i'll have a
checkmating attack against your king if
you allow rook
b6 takes b2 by the way your bishop is
hanging
i can't move any pieces white is
literally
white can't move any pieces he can't
move his rook because his bishop will
hang
or his pawn on f4 will hang after the
king moves
he can't move his bishop because the e4
pawn will hang he can't move his king
because a check of some kind will pick
off either his b b-pawn or maybe his
e-pawn
he literally can't move any piece he
can't move any pawns
he decided to finally capture on v6 rook
takes b6 with a beasty threat of rook
takes b2
you can't even play b4 because he'll
take on passant and queen that thing on
you
i mean you you can't you can't move
anything
right maybe e5 is playable finally but
that's going to allow rook takes b2
check
followed by real quite before and i
expect on passant
to happen i think it's sound
maybe maybe not if you take on takes is
there a
rook g6 rook
no you don't have enough you don't have
enough time to do it all
look back to f6 or rook takes c3 also
magnus has captured on passant this is
this is the problem you can take on
you could take on d3 with your king and
then on b2
sacrifice your rook on g6 and then play
king back to c2 congratulations you have
stopped this pawn from queening
on four and and you might say well i'm
you know at least i'm
still in the game but you're not
yeah this is completely lost with 21
seconds left
he's seconds on the clock and ticking
for fabby as he's
as he's facing an opening disaster and
he has
gone for your move king takes and we see
b2 on the board
now it's either rook g he played with g6
he played rogue g6 rook g6 on the board
rook takes g6
is on the board c2 now we can go
rook b6 if we like or i like rook b6
you know what i like b66 because after
king f6
i'm going to ask you again what your
next move
king b1 and rook and then this move i
guess you do have bishop eight
seven to last one one more one more move
that's kind of funny actually
after king f6 bishop and he has played
it bishop to eight seven
and now he can just trade off and start
pushing the a pawn
and fabi knows this is over he's still
hoping
against hope that there's some kind of
miracle
way yeah well
if we get king and bishop
versus king and rook and black has an
a pawn i'm just wondering if there
aren't some
really weird and they've gone right down
this variation by the way
everybody they've gone right down the
variation and
what fabi has done is he's he's trying
to use
one of his pawns as a decoy and maybe
both of those pawns to pick off this
pawn on b2
and to be able to play king and bishop
versus king rook and
apon whenever you have such an
endgame like this and you're the
superior side do not
do not push your pawn quickly forwards
drive the defending king out of the
corner before
doing any of that and after king c5 what
did we have
f6 all the trades as we expected
saying patience is a virtue yes
absolutely so
here the only thing the only thing
that's a problem for black
is that the king is right next to the
promotion square
so imagine that we could put the king
anywhere in
any other corner then we could promote
the pawn for free
so uh that's what you need to do is
drive the king away and after
king b2 uh i my board isn't updating for
some strange reason
we've got the board we've got the
position here though on the screen
so we can follow
yeah we see rookie 7 bishop g6 and the
big board
um this is the position we have in front
of us with 28 seconds left for fabiano
i got to tell you if a position this
position that he's gotten on the board
which actually is a 53 mover so far
i'm surprised he even got this far just
to be honest
you know you could argue hey i didn't
lose in 30 moves i didn't lose to a king
side attack
i didn't resign i mean whatever you know
you got all those little arguments that
you could make
but i actually agree with you maurice in
this case because i think
also that like having getting actually
checkmated
and you know resigning 10 minutes ago
would have been worse
because he's kind of chilling out you
know
remember it's all about keeping your
psychological fortitude in clutch
yes because you need that three-pointer
game not to feel like you're getting
demolished
right uh surprise move there for me the
move rook d6 i thought the rook was
great on d2
i expected something like king here rook
here
and check to start to drive the king out
of the box
didn't happen he dropped back with his
king and just king up to
d to b2 sorry ooh
a4 the the very the very thing i
prescribed
to avoid doing he just jumped ahead and
he said i can win this game even if your
king's
in the corner baby says show me
i'm from missouri a3
check on the board and whites
hanging around hanging around guys
king b1 rook d7 by magnus
magnus has shown a slight uncertainty
so far but now it looks like he is going
for it
and he is clear on the fact that it's
indefensible once he's gotten his pawn
to a2 now you cannot stop the mating
problems that are going to come your way
as he's created on this setup and simply
enough just don't take the bishop
don't take money don't take the bishop
we haven't seen stalemate in a long time
by the way i mean we see all kinds of
checkmates each and every time
but not a stalemate here goes the last
trick by fabi hoping for rookie one but
now
just a simple rook g2 and you have to
move the bishop and you will get mated
and so it is
over magnus shaking his head saying huh
man it shouldn't have lasted 65
moves wow
well magnus carlsen what a move you know
this uh
e4 idea clearance of the e5 square
very instructional moment guys true
but you needed that move right the worst
piece was the knight and so you'd have
to think to yourself how do i get my
knight
in this game the move e4 calls
for itself rook to e1 rook 8e1
that was simply just a reflex move
i should double my rooks no way
no way that maybe rook f1 bishop d5
certainly was the more uh incisive move
the bishop give up your pawn your bishop
is a bad piece where it stands
give up this pawn and look for
variations here maybe bishop c6
would make sense maybe bishop e4
wouldn't make sense but this is
i would say that bishop c6 would have to
be calculated bishop c6
and takes on c6 would have to be the
line that you actually
calculate to see whether or not you can
get away with it although it does look
dangerous leaving
at this moment with your queen to be
honest but this seems more like
how you'd want to play more tenacious at
least
rook to e1 had no value you cannot waste
a single move
when you play against a guy like you you
just gotta be
vigilant at all times too for the
tactics and
it's like black this is where the
fantasy comes in for both you and your
opponent
you know with black you're fantasizing
about getting your knight to f3
most times it doesn't work that moment
you seize it
but guys doesn't this look like just
like a
beautiful setup for some tactical
puzzle book where you come to class and
say
okay everybody put on your thinking caps
like to move and win
and you start to look and then the
geometry is beautiful the knight on the
c6 square is
not participating and what would be
ideal
to put it on e5 and you play e4 just the
time that
the rook is tethered to the f two pawn
and you
can't take with the rook because
actually you walk into a fork as well
so takes knight e5 bishop e6
and knight d3 and it's all just
it's just a beautiful sequence that
would have won
the game this way if mag if
pardon me if abby hadn't given up the
exchange could we see the move
could we see nice uh rook
i want to see two moves i just want to
see the analysis to this
the move rook f1 instead of rook e1
which rook f1 is a movie you really
don't want to play because it
blocks your uh blocks your queen
and you're that's a good that's a good
point yes because what if what if this
was like a real tournament game like a
real blitz game and you touched the rock
and then you realized rookie one was a
blunder then like rook f1 would
definitely be the best option right
i was thinking actually that he was
actually going to play rook d3
i really like what maurice was saying i
want to play bishop
d5 but you know my aversion to
a sacrificing pawns so the move rook d1
to protect the pawn on d3 would have
caught my notice i agree wholeheartedly
that rook e1 was
what wasted the tempo and it was
actually misplacing the rook
but that's the first part but let's just
analyze this for a second does e4
still come with authority in this line
it looks to it i mean let's say i could
go rook takes the rotation is always d5
so that one
is always respected by d5 so pawn takes
so let's see pawn takes
yep and now knight e5 now knight d3
doesn't come with any effect at all
so let's see bishop here and you can't
move the rook because f4
is possible so
even i mean why why is your knight d3
not interesting to you anymore
why is knight d3 not interesting i'm
still running knight f2
yeah that's why the bishop when d5 is so
strong huh
and then i don't have time to take on f2
because you just played bishop takes f3
i still think black's better clearly but
this i mean especially with this knight
in rook on this
square you can't get rid of them and the
queen is trapped
yeah exactly we've been referring to
uh alpha zero remember the alpha zero
put the pawn to
h6 kind of routine well here the queen
on g2
kind of makes like a very ugly looking
impression
you could even play i don't know
something really
you've got a lot of time it white is all
tied up maybe you want to play g5 g4 so
an
f4 doesn't come at the moment you move
your rook
it looks like this would have been very
good to magnet for magnus
absolutely but this is at least a
positional sacrifice right this is not a
tactical one
that's what i really like about the move
e4 you call it tactical
it's a clearance sack so you can get to
the e5 square and improve
your worst piece what was the one piece
not working the knight on c6
you play e4 and get that knight to that
beautiful square as we see the score
here 1-0
you get the knight to that square and
the rest takes care of itself
we don't even see brilliancies after
that absolutely and it's that
merging in chess of the tactical with
the strategic
which is the beauty of the game it's
about calibrating those two elements
when you've got a move that um hits high
scores on both
that's uh that's a great testament and
they're back
magnitude d4 game two underway
d4 we saw a london system
pardon me we saw a london system
yesterday uh but this looks like a much
more of a queen's gambit decline
hey a7 a6 now that's rude
fabi plays the very variation that
magnus himself
has been championing on and off for
about five years
uh a7 a6 saying to magnus
okay i'm gonna play your variation
against you
how what's the best what's the best line
and uh magnus says you dirty rat fink
you you're playing my stuff against me
how dare you
i think for bobby the first step guys it
sounds weird because you just got hit
i think the first step for fabi is um to
at least get on the scoreboard
because if he gets the turning record
you're saying
yeah i mean right now i mean yes exactly
that that and also just the fact that
strategically if he gets on the
scoreboard
he will always have a chance to um
strike back in a clutch game and win the
match
are you saying he's worried about losing
4-0 well
i mean not gonna i don't think he's
worried about it per se but i'm just
saying
as it turns out even if you were to lose
three and a half half
you would still be able to get back and
wipe that all out with one clutch game
man if you that is true that is
generally speaking true i mean that is
factually true
but if you lose three and a half half
and
you're so demoralized you can't imagine
that the guy's not gonna win another
game
out of the next two you might get back
in it with three with three
well with the clutch game but a guy
beats you up three and a half half
that's you're probably going to go down
although young jeffrey young might
say wait a second i lost three in a row
and drew the fourth one so i was down
three and a half half against magnus
and then i hit him in the fifth game so
it is possible and has been done against
magnus already
so we will watch for that and this time
it's a three-pointer so
it is not not something fabi can
hope though for again that would be
that that would be ugly it would be
demoralizing no doubt
totally but i've always stopped
keeping your composure keep your
composure keep your
your equilibrium don't feel bad if you
can do that
and stay with that attitude into the
clutch games fabio will have a chance no
matter how badly it goes
i always thought that in these positions
white was aspiring for the move b2b4
and i thought queen c2 was the telltale
sign
queen c2 back here
on move 13 right here uh
you want to protect the knight so that
you can go b4 so queen c2 to my mind
has that threat i always thought as
black you're supposed to play
a5 to try to make it like
make it awkward to do the minority
attack g6 so i'm expecting
b4 rook fc1 no b4
so i'm expecting a5 no a5
the guy who had queen e7 instead and uh
pretty surprising to me that neither
player seems to have thinks that
b4 was the way to go knight a4 on the
board
and fabi has just played the move knight
e8
looking to reroute the knight to the d6
square so that
maybe he'll play f5 and play knight c4
or just keep the situation flexible
at last somebody
somebody feels my angst and magnus has
played the move b4
which i've always thought was favorable
for white if he could get it in
and i always thought that it was
incumbent upon black
to play a5 to make it difficult so for
me
this is clear advantage white
just study the old master sami rushevsky
uh as he made a very comfortable living
on the white side of the minority attack
the carlsbad
pawn structure as did you yes as well
well
i mean i was following his footsteps uh
knight b6 on the board by fabi is he's
eyeballing
the c4 square for a potential
uh hop with his knight and he had a
positional threat as well
bishop to f5 was black's positional
threat
trying to undermine this bishop that
guards the c4 square
so that he could plant a knight on c4
and not have
too many worries so magnus decided
to take on e6 immediately as you're
showing there yes this line
is what he was hoping for that he'd be
able to get his piece
to c4 safely and if one night challenge
well he'd had a backup
knight takes now on e6 though and fabi
stopping to think
and finally decided to play queen takes
on e6
and again magnus said i don't want you
to see the c4 square so i'm going
to play the move knight to d2 i know
what you want
but you're not going to get it and now
i'm back to my business about playing
for a4
now a4a5 yes what do you feel about that
can he ever play this move because
oh yes how does he continue his minority
attack if he
if he's going to play a pawn on a5 it
was a
massively massively important game
between
anatoly karpov and ulf anderson's from
the gma straleftio
uh world cup event where
anatoly was doing all of these fantastic
maneuvers and
and uh ulf was defending his
one weakness on b7 and
all i can say is that it's a torture
it's it by no means is it his definitive
victory for white or
anything like that it just it's just
going to require
constant whoa we
saw something very different constant
vigilance i wanted to say by black to
hold the game
i thought that magnus was trying to keep
the knight out of the square c4 with the
move knight d2 i
think this move rook e1 somehow
allowed fabi to jump
to c4 and he did it instantly oh yeah he
played b5 behind it
yes and this is a well-known recipe
against this
minority attack as well white will be
able to open the a file
with rook a2 rook a1 that would be his
whole but black gets his counter play on
the other
side there's some f4 possibilities if
you're not careful
and fabi has just planted his knight on
e4 magnus was
leaning towards the
right of our screen towards his
left and now he's leaning the other way
both he's not centered the way fabi is
the first time we were looking at him he
was he was on his
his head was on his left hand and
leaning that way relaxed
and then he turns and he relaxes the
other way so every position from magnet
seems like
i'm just going to relax no matter how i
play he's got
he's got the the shorts on again as he's
just lounging but he's got the
he's got my position when i'm watching
netflix
when i'm in a tournament i'm playing
online
i mean i got my face nose to the screen
yeah everyone's different like that
though and we've seen more recent we've
seen rather magnus and very relaxed
poses playing in the world championship
right easy to get confused marie sorry
about that yeah me and max
magnus
we got the m a to start i think that's
the end of it
it's all right right but easy
easy easy confusion to make there uh
jen i'm with you 100 um okay
this unfortunately for me it reminds me
of a game
that i played with gary kasparov if i
was on the white side gary planted
the knight on c4 i didn't like it he
misplayed it in a time trouble scramble
but my feeling is
it's much easier to play black bishop
takes e4
wow okay well if i'm black this is real
and automatic to open up
the f file f5 takes e4
uh fabi actually is
reflecting he's not jumping immediately
for this so
is he afraid of knight e5
what do you think why would you be
afraid of knight e5
well he's finally captured that way he's
taken that way that's right yes
it would be too painful not to and then
95 was played
that was probably what caused him to
hesitate and now he's gone queen b6 okay
queen c3 that's an automatic you defend
the knight
and you defend the pawn and the good
news is
that the a file is now contestable that
is to say
white could potentially play rook a8
rook a8 rook
a1 and say hey let's fight over
uh dominance on the a file so maybe
magnus has slipped the noose here a
little bit
because it looked like fabby was getting
the upper hand
it did it did um but i mean don't you
you don't like black anymore i mean
because you don't think we have time to
play like rook f5 and rook f8
now that are now you have the a file
control well
exactly the a file is the issue if you
have to play
for example rook e 8
and i for example play rook c6
a6 hitting c6 yeah pardon me rook a6
hitting c6
i'm thinking i i can give as as good as
you
can on the f-file i can attack your pawn
so
i kind of feel like white's chances are
no worse
in such a light and we saw queen f6 by
the way that's what i mean f6 that makes
a lot of sense so we're just treating
that pawn on f2
you can't play rook f1 because we why
because then we take on a1 and play
knight d2
which would be winning let's do that
let's do that nice
nice nice so hitting then
hitting the rook that's defending the
pawn be careful there's a counter shot
there's a fork you've set up against
yourself with an id
so it's also so just be mindful queen f6
did
and i played rook f1 and he he is seeing
that counter shot
of knight to d7 and then at the end of
the line if we play like queen g5
with the idea that after knight f8
knight f3 check it doesn't lead to any
mate
you just play king h1 at the end of the
day it's not going anywhere
queen g5 actually
you're asking for it in this line no
yeah
just you just haven't had escape square
for sure
so rook f1 on the board
time has i i've jennifer i haven't been
paying that much attention uh
they're pretty even on the clocks
they're pretty even today
magnus is not getting down on the clock
today like he did yesterday
it was is that a kind of that was a
story that was a big story yesterday
right
yeah maybe he realized after the games
that that that was part of the problem
as um you know he spoke so so frankly
um about how he felt he played better
yesterday
but you know especially in that last
game was frustrated
not to end ahead of bobby yes indeed i
think his first game though
that's right at the ship quite a bit and
certainly
whoever his coaches are they're saying
remember the clock remember the time
of the clock play quickly if you if you
play quickly and naturally you are
magnus carlsen the pieces will land on
the right squares
you'll be fine and that is what he has
to deal with and now queen to e6
this is looking more more balanced folks
this one looks like
it should be drawn more or less
neither side has any real thing to play
for there are no obvious pawn breaks
f3 is the only one for white and i don't
think it's a move white wants to play
that's that said what does black want to
do as a pawn break
doesn't look like it exists there's no
c5 there's no
there's no nobody there's no pawn breaks
anywhere so it just looks like they both
have to sit here and watch each other
from afar as we do see
that uh magnus is thinking and wondering
about this position
the only literally the only break on the
board
is f3 well black
black can't engineer a g4
white could think about h4h5 but
who's backing that up nobody
i mean there are no breaks there's this
is this is a question of
the a file the only open file on the
board
currently that you can have access to
but black is ready to play
some move like queen c8 to defend his
rook and not give you the a file so for
example if magnus plays rook takes eight
right now and rook takes and then plays
rook a1
queen can just drop back c8 maybe e8 as
well and say
what are you you're not getting the file
i'm not giving it to you you're
just like that's not going to happen so
what are you going to do are you going
to play for f3 now
what are you supposed to do yeah here it
i'm i'm having an intro
internal struggle it's something i don't
want to do i
don't want to capture on c4 but it did
occur to me that if i did capture on c4
either with four rooks on the board or
two rooks on the board
i could try to move rook a5 and
leverage it to the hilt with queen a3
it better i'm giving a protected pass
pawn on c4 so
yes you know we caught him very
reluctant to do that
and a weak pawn on b4 as well white
black could shift his attention to your
b-pawn
you'll be defending that and wondering
why you traded on c4 so
magnus didn't want to have anything to
do with the conception he did play the
move rook fc one
let's just see it again knight takes
pawn takes rook a5
now the one thing i don't think black
should be interested in
is trading rooks and giving white a very
dangerous past pawn
you said maurice we you could switch yes
now paul could switch files and go for
the b file
and i get the a file all right but
maybe there's just i mean
i don't know how i would get anything
going
on the a file necessarily
so that was why we saw magnus just say
okay i'm
chill rook fc one and by the way
we didn't see queen f6 and a repetition
we these players have been hungry for
victory
they have not ever gone for repetitions
it seems to me
like everybody wants to play for a win
and
rook c2 that's okay that's a different
way
of playing resting control of the a file
right that is a sneaky mode
now you cannot now you can't compete for
the
the file this is that
clever this is problematic that king g7
it wasn't just about the cleverness it
was king g7
that caused this little issue in the
position maybe
maybe he could have played a bit a bit
more accurately here but now that i'm
looking at it he has to be ready to
compete for the file himself now he's
brought his king back to g8
what that's not a good sign now what
happens if he
if he takes over the file does white and
magazines
didn't need any invitation to do so
but i guess his thought is that he wants
his king on g8 so that if he plays like
a temple move like
oh no look at this it wasn't
it's turned everything around incredible
shots
not just overlook this track by fabi
fabian has tricked him
show us what happened guys oh that was
really magnificent devastated
he cannot believe he allowed this that
was
you talking about a dirty rat that was
messy boy
yes right here white had played this
really clever move roxy too
as he intimates he's ready to challenge
the a file take over it
and fabi said oh gosh i missed that move
well let me make a move
and very happily
bananas as now the point of king g8 is
revealed
after 95 pawn e5 d4 clearing the line
for the queen you don't have
the in-between mover k7 jack oh that is
something
that is hustle chess at its finest that
was
extraordinary and now suddenly he has a
pass
deep on right now d3
how did he get this position that that
was slick
i'm sorry you know bobby by the way
grew up in brooklyn learned chess in
brooklyn that's one of brooklyn's finest
right there
that is a serious trickery
it's all about that poker face when he
plays king g8 like yeah
i messed it up i gave you the a file i
wanted to say
washington square park hustlers are
beaming right now
trust me we got prospect park
we got ronald mcnair park we got fulton
park
we've got washington square park we got
st nicholas park
we get a ton of parks in new york and
they're all going
bobby you can come hang with us come
here what a way
to trick the world champion and magnus
was just in shock
from a position where it looked like
everything was quiet and he was the one
about to take over suddenly he is just
in deep trouble and his e pawn looks
like he's going to die
rogue d5 exactly it should be able to
get this pawn
the the king is marching up into the
position to e6
white's king can't pretend to be able to
do the same
black just needs to consolidate though
he's he's still focused
look at fabi he knows even though he's
got in this great position he managed to
trick his opponent
magnus is not just going to go down
magnus is going to fight back
and we saw that many times guys remember
magnus is hardly untrickable
he also got tricked multiple times by
jeffrey jean right but he actually
won some of those games that he got
tracked so
you know and but okay he doesn't really
have as much counter play in the
this game as he had in some of those but
still um fabi has to be vigilant to win
this game because that king on g8 will
always be a little weak if queens stay
on the board
absolutely absolutely and past pawns
they're difficult to get all the way
home when you have queen and rook
endings
okay just very tricky to get them all
the way there
because you can't overcome the
opposition
wow i'm not sure i'm a big fan of this
move by
well i don't know what to do and frankly
i think it's a very very bad position
for magnus but queen a1
basically saying okay d2 rook d1
queen here i'm stuck for a move
and i think his intention like you were
saying jen
is like when the queens are on the board
so long as the queens are on the board
there's always an
outside chance of a perpet perpetual
check
something against the black king but i'm
not feeling it
exactly here i think there are multiple
ways of winning this position for that
for fabby he's just got to choose one to
his shows your way
d3 d2 and queen b3
is on the board my only concern is with
these blockaders
it's never easy just to push
through if you win b4 yes e6
ditching the e pawn i'm taking that
that's got to do of course
oh that's got to die he's got a question
he's got to die
and he took it and now the queen back
and now you have to defend
and this is what i'm saying so let's
where is your max play here you play
queen d5
and what do you plan to do
c5 is a worry for me so what if i and he
has played it
what if he plays queen c3 leaves his
queen on c3 or c2 even
and just sits what is your winning plan
uh
easy uh for me to say uh
hard to implement when you're playing
against magnus carlsen first of all
i'm always thinking about the queen
dropping
in and making some perpetual checks so
king f7 comes to mind right away
a move like rook d d6 uh
also to stop a queen from coming to f6
and what i really want to do
is just make sure that when i'm ready to
go queen d3
queen e2 you got no chance of perpetual
checks
maybe i even want my pawns on the king
side to look like this
pawn on g5 pawn on h4 by the way queen
c3
again one of those moves that i don't
want to see land on the board is queen
h8 so anytime
so it's a this combination of let's
avoid
any kind of counter attacks against the
king
and let's put my king in the most safest
square possible
i'm hearing you yes but the problem with
queen and rook endings
is it's very difficult to lift the
blockader very difficult so you want to
get your queen to e2
and then even if i gave you queen e2
if i gave you queen e2 my queen was
sitting on c2 what would you do
you have a rook you have a potential
rook f8
issue that could
no because then i take on then i take on
d2 so what do you plan to do
with with a queen on c2 now you also
have a queenie one idea that chases my
king away from my f-pawn
that is a problem as well so okay
i i still feel like it's not easy
baby is basically setting up
for something even i think even more
direct
i think he's setting up for a queen
d3 force the trait of king queens
and then just to try to march the king
to c4 i mean
that's pretty in your face
if you know about that but he's not i'm
not trading queens we need queens
queen's office i'm dead there's no way
the queen's leaving the board
so if i keep queens on and i eyeball
your
your d-pawn i don't let you take
something
on the b4 square and protect your pawn
simultaneously that would be bad news
for me
so i just keep this position and if you
ever try to
shift your your pieces a certain way my
queen shows up
somewhere for example if you ever play
h5 my queen will always think about g7
right so the queen's on d3 right now
now this queen and queen a2 check this
is where i'm worried
where exactly do i get security here
if you're like rook d5 what about queen
eight
is your king actually getting out yeah
that's the whole thing is
you know the the perpetual checks right
so rook d5
queen a8 rook d6 and i got this crazy
notion that if my king could ever get to
c4 i'd be
super super that's happening queen g8
check is is coming or queen
actually even queenie h and then queen
f7 check
you're not getting you're not leaving
you're not leaving
i'm concerned exit stage left is the
truth
stay you better hang around with this
this is what i'm worried about
he's better but now look at him he's
shifting his king and magnus has checked
him a few times this king is going to
have to find
maybe a hideo can the king hide on h6
is that something he could do queen a2
check and by the way while we've been
talking
fabi went from having three and a half
minutes to 140
to having one minute to 140.
so he's not finding a way in himself
this is not easy he's got his rook back
to d7 this is just
not an easy end game where does the king
go well should the king
hide out h6 might be your hideout
is b7 a hideout oh definitely
yeah i mean it would be very nice to
step
across the board on a king march all the
way
over the problem as i saw it in terms of
getting the king to b7
the moment you step back to d8 there was
a check
and you i was probably driving you back
to
e7 anyway okay wait a minute
queen a1 on the board and now
the queen could go to c2 and that
freezes your position that does
freeze well there's always a check right
queen g7 check yeah but then i can move
the king to the queen side which is what
we want to do
he's played king d6 queen c2 could have
kept you
honest not give your queen any liberties
but he is trying to get his king now
to that b7 square where you know it
could be some challenges
so magnus now looking at the position
bobby down to 31 seconds
thorny end game he had three minutes but
he couldn't figure it out
this is not an easy one he's now playing
the move king to h2
and now we also have queenie two ideas
back to the queen c2 ideas
king c7 is not playable at the moment
and he's backed his queen up he's backed
his queen up he didn't see anything in
there he's threatening queen e5
that's what he's threatening queenie
five trade queens that's that's
gonna have to go back to g1 right or i
mean yeah
but where is white where is a black's
progress
in this oh but the c5 move by the way
and now he's played king to
e6 not sure what to do and magnus's
queen
has landed on h8 this is not what we
wanted to have happen too many checks to
calculate with 15
if we go back like 10 moves when the
king was on g8
and the rook was on d8 he could have
played h5 king h7
and just created a little cushion a
little pocket for his king
and again he was looking to play king c7
was um fabi and getting against king to
the queen side queen b8
really this is what you're supposed to
do whenever you're
in a difficult position is you just got
to think to yourself
make things hard on my opponent here it
is
queen to b3 a concrete winning threat
but queen
to e5 and now king over is this king
escaping
king queen of check white is on the edge
of a precipice right now
because he can't deal with queen d1 or
maybe his queen can get to g4
and then he'll deal with it from there
but he doesn't want to play such a move
can the king will move
seconds for fabi bobby cannot be happy
now he's
he's gonna have to repeat at least four
seconds three okay
he's finally played king g7 queen e5
check and magnus not giving him
any breaks as he understands there's a
really strong drawing chance now
for white okay i think that white should
avoid playing queen h8 check and taking
a pawn
because then magnus by me then fabi
could hide step it
over to the queen side and this queen f4
check that was
really clever uh in my estimation
and look at this i mean replacing
quickly king e8 looking to that doesn't
repeat because you can't move your king
to d8
that that's just pure repetition that
doesn't make any progress is what i
meant to say
right yeah magnus now i think it's a
threefold denise
oh no
oh no so far
trick magnus survive what is what a game
two games in which two games which
almost spun
on the the clearance tactic right i mean
this was another example
of clearing a line for that queen on e6
but unlike for magnus carlsen fabiano
that big edge not enough to get it done
due to the time scramble and the
complexity of shielding
all those tracks the problem
the problem queen rook endings
even with past pawns difficult to lift
the blockading
piece this is the problem and especially
if you have an exposed king
it's just not technically easy otherwise
probably would have just said bing bing
bing
and found all the moves but his king was
always under perpetual harassment
and he had to find the moment with time
ticking down
that
and we're going to take a quick break
and show you some clutch moments from
fabiano's career
[Music]
after forcing a playoff by defeating
michael adams in the final round of the
2017
london chess classic fabiano caruana
faced another do or die situation
if he wanted to win the champions trophy
with the most exciting finale a playoff
between
the familiachi and fabiano caruana and
indeed the games have begun
and we see a knight of three again in
terms of
something something didn't go as planned
for fabio he's uh he has one
for that exchange he has not maximized
the position he had knight e2
that's right somebody's flying oh he
offered to draw
yeah i i think he offered the draw and
then
okay okay
yeah the final position it's all black
the players getting
get settled in they
and they're set up for the second uh
blitz game and this is either the last
game or the penultimate game now
exactly and his king has been exposed
whoa what is this what's the clock times
seven seconds for each player oh my god
it's unwatchable
oh my gosh it's impossible to watch this
no get quick
why did the legs change the queens oh
this is tough for the nerves one second
left oh
check check check it came over there we
have it
the most dramatic fashion possible
[Music]
since 2009 our mission has always been
to teach and promote the value chess
brings to our community in these times
of social distancing it's more important
than ever
that we stay connected to carry on that
mission we are currently offering 24
weekly classes online through
our youtube and twitch channels we're
also holding tournaments and private
lessons online
from the comfort of their own home
students can enjoy all the benefits of
our scholastic chess initiative
digitally
our scholastic outreach continues with
virtual chess classrooms
scholastic tournaments and scouts bsa
merit badge workshops
on behalf of everyone at the saint louis
chess club we hope you and your loved
ones stay safe and continue to watch
play and enjoy the game of chess
can you hear it it's the sound of hope
and health and strength
it's the sound of compassion of open
doors
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
it's the sound of personalized
healthcare and active communities
it sounds like life and it's what you
hear
when you really listen
[Music]
and we are back at clutch chess
as we'll take a look at the current
score well magnus hit hard in the first
game
actor opening but some
excellent middle game play and a nice
move
e4 hirano looked poised to do the very
same thing with by the way the mirror
opposite of the move d4
right on the other side of the board but
a very similar clearing
move but unfortunately magnus was able
to
mix it up in the time pressure and hold
the draw
that was one of the most beautiful traps
i've seen and the way it was set up by
gabby with this move king g8 and rook a2
uh played allah tempo and d-player oh
that was just oh that was great
i am stunned seriously i thought fabi
was going to even
the match up he's come back each and
every time in day one whenever he fell
behind
he got the victory right back i thought
that game
was his fantastic defense from magnus
carlson fantastic a little
less shocked only because with the open
king
and magnus's notorious resourcefulness
it's like it didn't seem like it was
gonna be
um easy without a fight for bobby it
never is when you're playing magnus is
it it never
is but i wasn't going to be a walk in
the park you were going to be walking
apart no matter who you played
that position is very difficult to win
with that rook sitting on d1
well let's see we're going to see
whether or not magnus repeats
his idea and now more principally this
time
the move c3 by fabi going for what
you should do go open up the game play
for d4
and show the guy what you got and now b5
and sure certainly magnus has had this
position
on the board before uh with his bishop
on d6 so we'll see
as his knight goes to e7 will fabi go
for the push right away
nope he's played d3 first he can get an
a4 moving
a little bit later as well but certainly
d4 was something that
yes had calculated and i was so curious
about
what that would have i'm so curious to
maurice about what that would have led
to because it is the move crying out to
be played with the bishop on d6
but clearly fabi didn't think it
amounted to enough so just played d3
instead
yeah i mean i i'm just thinking that it
might have been
something based on
the bishop on c2 being hanging i don't
know uh
d3 uh slow play sorry maurice
and castles has occurred i would say
these players have seconds
we know that rustom kasimchanov is a
second of fabi's
famously so and you can imagine after
magnus played bishop d6 the first time
he might have said well somebody was
busy didn't expect that one
and may have gone to work or somebody
somewhere don't know maurice because i
don't know if they have enough time
because like you know the
anti-electronics roles are so strict
do you really think that between going
to the bathroom and getting a glass of
water in between games they have to like
they have time to check their messages
and turn off their phone i
i'm not sure we could ask chris byrd
about that but
first of all we don't know we we don't
know how the setup is
in terms of yeah maybe he just says
listen what you should do is play
c3 uh go for d3 or don't do d4
and play a4 and play that position yeah
you would only have a
couple you only have a minute or so to
get any kind of advice if you do have it
so by the way you're not going to the
bathroom every single break
i mean like you got to go five times
right
so if he gets he gets four five minutes
maybe that's the five minutes well spent
water and coffee you drink guys
a drink of water yeah but he's
always listen to your coach that's my
advice
[Laughter]
all right we've got a position here with
knight h4 by the way i
that's an intriguing move because i was
actually thinking
that uh fabi might play for night here
which
when you look at it it starts to really
you start to warm up to the task
because you're thinking that the bishop
on d6 stops you from playing d6 the pawn
on c5
is potential harassment over here uh
maybe he was afraid of f5 i
don't know exactly how how to evaluate
this position
in any case i think it was the move f5
that caused fabi to play the move knight
h4
and now we have rook yates just playing
to stop
f5 rookie completely avoiding any idea
for f5 that's a
that's interesting
i mean when magnus carlsen plays a movie
you you add
you gotta at least pay a little bit more
attention before you
suggest what to do next but now it just
looks like white himself has a
nice position where a matter of fact
what is mac what
what are magnus's next several moves uh
i don't know what he's planning to do
i i can imagine he might want to play
queen b6 and rook d8 connect the rooks
but i don't know i mean to to my eyes
you know take the pawn go after the pawn
d2 and allowed knight f5 with oh that
was the point of rookie eight so he
could put his bishop back on the f8
square
makes sense that was the point but he
did seem to lose
well he's going to play for knight e7
eventually
queen g played and now we know what's
coming next because we've been seeing
these guys he's going to get that h45
in exactly a whole 13 moves to finally
for perry i know
slowly slowly you know
don't rush maurice you know
but i agree with you jen h4h5 big time
on white's agenda
yes this knight on f5 as we all know
from these rui lopez
and all those king pawn defenses
once you get a knight on f5 you can
leverage that to an attack
uh with the queen and we're looking at
h4h5 and
so is magnus now magnus sitting there
saying
okay i mean h4h5 coming do i
play d6 bishop c8 and
extract this guy or am i ready to
you have to be careful for example let
me just put some move on the board uh
d6 let's say stage and let's say you're
thinking to yourself
oh i i'm going to sacrifice a pawn
with a move like knight f4 well hold up
sacrifice is slightly bigger than a pawn
yeah it's a great it's a girl
i mean that's it that's the end of the
game so
uh when when the knight moves from g6
you have to be able to meet uh
knight h6 as a potential so
maybe you start with king h8 but then
you got to deal with h4
let's say let's let's make a move h4
let's make another move and after h5
okay how
how would you kill me
hmm well you you know i hate
provocative questions ooh wait a minute
you you started by saying how would i i
hung upon
how would i kill you and
i i don't i don't want to have to be
forced to kill you when i already have a
better position
why can't i just i'll play you he just
played from this great position now d6
h4 is coming
it's not a maybe i see you like that
bishop c5 idea that after knight f5
bishop takes f8
with a potential mate threat just taking
a kind of nice pawn
yeah so let's just see uh i think
this would have been much safer uh
method for for uh magnus to deal with
this
quickly building king side attack by the
way look at the times
now it's getting serious that's nine
minutes to six jeff that's right
this i can say now magnus's trainers
are saying what the heck happened here
this has been a disaster
as he's trying to defend this big
initiative and they've got
they're looking quickly as to see what
he should do next game when he walks out
and they'll say
listen when you have black again do this
this this and this okay got it boom if
he plays the same i think we'll see
i think we will we'll see we won't see a
repeat of this opening because we've got
to watch this game
yeah because we've got one more black
for magnus after this this is his
penultimate black in the event unless
there's a tie break
i think he's going to switch it up to e5
guys that's my
i think that would be a good idea the
sicilians have been great
fun for us but maybe they've been a
little bit too
topsy-turvy for the world champion's
tummy
and don't forget that magnus knows that
it's not necessarily a huge negative for
him for the time control to get faster
and faster
so i just have a hunch that he might do
that now that's assuming that the score
is equal or um you know
better for him going into the last game
by the way a king i don't have to win
both for that not to be the case
a king moving off of h8 every time
somebody makes a move
there's a weakness created some kind of
drawback that's just the reality of
chess
that's how it it works so you want to
always note these kind of things
of course fabi noted it quickly yeah
serenoi noted it quickly
bishop on b3 as you see the arrow
showing hey
tactic f7 is hanging thanks for moving
your king i don't have to play h5
immediately
how do you deal with your f pawn and
he's what
man he's played f6 and
all the tacticians in the world are
thinking
what's the sacrifice
that was my that was my that was your
move i'm sorry
i was distracted i was like zach
and win what is that about okay that uh
that that oh you pulled me there i was
looking at the wrong screen too many
screens in front of me
exactly that i mean okay obviously we
want to take a pawn
i mean that's the target uh but what
the move also intends is that
a moment ago oh excuse me
a moment ago if um we had played h5
knight
e7 uh was black's plan
he wasn't necessarily forced to
sacrifice upon with
knight f4 right so what
magnus did is so pardon me what fabi did
is he played bishop b3
to make knight e7 impossible
queen e7 eight c7 what's up with h5
precisely because now you can't play
this move knight e7 because
that's a whole okay so clearly this is a
this is a pawn cycling f4
let's go down this line because fabi's
furiously calculating this capture and
queen takes f4
and the clearance square e5 is now
available to the knight so knight to e5
is possible
with tempo on the d3 pawn but is this
real is is this not your kind of pony
ass
oh yeah oh yeah no that this is not
he didn't take it he did not take it
take it no
no he did not he played knight to f3 he
didn't want any parts of giving magnus
any play he said
my position's better i'm just going to
sit on it
and use this you know will he regret
this moment
when he could have just taken upon and
try to prove upon advantage he believed
magnus's potential counter player at
least felt that this position
was better than taking a pawn
uh and you have to say yeah right
give me the ball hey the pawn
there we go now knight a5 challenging
the bishop
maybe he has something like is fabby
looking at
tactics with knight g5 and queen h no
that just seems like a dream let's
calculate bishop f7 here
bishop f7 queen takes knight g5
and and now let's look i was a little
bit afraid of queen h5
okay let's keep yeah now i'm just
bluffing what about h5
and if you give this
up yeah i'm really bluffing here
i don't know if you're bluffing that bad
i couldn't look for a knight
g6 eventually a capture an h4
and it's a little bit of yeah it's too
much too risky right now bishop d5
wiser move and what i like about this
move is if you take on d5 e takes d5
then that knight on uh which has
occurred that knight on a5 is slightly
stranded
f6 he finally played it e6 is so weak
but i can't get a knight in there well i
think he was really afraid
of knight g5 frankly knight g5 with the
ideas of queen h5
and the knight re rerouting to e4 this
night
as you mentioned on a5 all all dressed
up with no
place to go so f7 f6 i
i i think uh i understand that move from
the defensive point of view but it is
fabi who's dictating the action h5
97 and the knight on a5 is
just a bad piece and will take a while
to show
back up in the game fabi now trading off
all the pieces
well trading off first the bishop good
enough now the knight
now another night h4 we talked about
this move
under tactical circumstances there is
a big threat right now of knight g6
sacking a piece and getting at that king
magnus said i'm not letting that happen
move the queen over
to f7 and now knight g6 would be met by
king to g8
well isn't it time just to play c4
b3 and permanently like lock
the barn door to not let the horsey
escape
play c4b3 and that horse
on a5 is out of action for quite some
time to come
um yeah i thought the knight was dead
anyway why do we need this move
well d5 was hanging ah
indeed so knight f5 didn't work and you
had to guard your pawn
okay i like it
uh we're being told that this move was a
mistake
actually what and i think it's great for
and now e4 on the board and b3
this is this i'm telling you hold on oh
wait a minute back up
back up yes take a look take a look one
move back
instead when you when he took on c4 was
correct bc4
bc dc4 but there's a one
which you would call a dirty rat move f5
oh no that's right stringing him out now
knight takes f5
knight takes c4
whoops and that would have been a
big turnaround in the game because you
can't play queen take c4 because if
queen takes f5
that was the way that how that's how
magnus should have played he missed
it and played e4 and allowed b3 and now
his knight is
truly locked out yes we have
everything king now moving to g8 fabi
with 6 38 on the clock
magnus with 245 but magnus's position
looks
awful right grim awful this he's lucky a
knight doesn't teleport to e6 but
why can't white just open up the game
and be a piece up like something like f3
and just say i'm a whole piece up your
knight has no route
back into civilization and actually he's
paying attention to the night
the knights headed back around uh
but it could go to d8 it can end up on
f7 not that that's a great square
but white's bishop is better white's
knight is better white's queen's better
there's an e pawn that looks like he's
going to die to my mind this
is strategically gone this is completely
lost
you just play rook to e1 you double
rooks on the e
file you play rook takes e4 and you very
kindly and humbly accept your opponents
or exaggeration
uh this is terrible i mean magnus has
just been completely
done in here strategically speaking his
knight is terrible his bishop is
terrible he's got
pawns can't move only his apon can move
nothing else can be touched
a5 a4 would be a little bit embarrassing
it's like okay your next turn
right you could you could be given these
two moves and nothing would be
and white would say okay you you want to
open up the a file
let's please go right ahead this is
completely crushing this is the second
game in a row
magnus has found himself in big trouble
now he's playing 55
this is this is so he can get his knight
to the d6 square
yeah i mean it's kind of amazing that
before the move rookie 5 it's a position
with equal material that it looks just
so
terrible for black now um now white is
actually up in exchange
did this remind it this this game has uh
echoes of the levon
aronian game where levon was killing
magnus
magnus sacrificed a pawn sacrificed the
second part then he sacrificed an
exchange
all in a desperate attempt to throw his
opponent off track
here he's just done the same the problem
is is that white's position is so
good as you were mentioning jen you know
it's like your material up
and you've got the great position to go
with along with it so
i mean i'm surprised you mentioned that
game
this feels more like the game fabi
sacrifice in exchange
against against him yesterday hoping to
get a strong blockading piece
right now that strong about getting
piece is going to be an anemic looking
bishop
on d6 as knight takes d6 is going to
occur
and then he's going to take the pawn on
e4 he's going to be up so much his rook
is now on the far i mean
this is just a completely dominating
position with no counter play
anywhere to speak of maybe he could get
an f5
actually even if he gets an f5 e4
bobby's gonna play f3 and say
thank you very much for that hook later
on even if he could get this because now
he can take the pawn
actually could take two this is what i
was talking about this move is his hope
and prayer
down three minutes on the clock and the
point is he could play for e4
eventually but f3 will just be in
white's favor
uh they've gone down this line only
uh the only difference is fabi said i
don't want to open up the
h line uh i may one day want to
put my king here so go ahead have your
f5
but let's do it with the h file closed
and we've got the same position white
upon a head and an exchange as well
f2 f3 making it that much harder for
for magnus to play the move wow uh
f4 magnus just captured on h5
which looks like a dead pawn on h5 now
he's he's going he's just going wild
because i thought king f2 and rook h1
would be enough to end the game but
maybe madison is going to put his queen
on the
oh he can't leave until queen h5 happens
i'm thinking he's going to play an e4
break e4 and get his queen sneaky but
he's even if his queen
or squeaky get to d4 that would be the
trick so to play for e4 and somebody get
the queen over to d4
is that going to be real what if king f2
now
with the straightforward rook h1 idea
are you allowing some trickies
that's what i'm worried about that's
that's that's the thing i'm worried
about
he's played rook to e3 soft pedaling it
a little bit
he's not letting his opponent uh get
well but not king h8 i
you know when you start slowing down is
when bad things happen
you just start slowing down a little bit
too much i think magnus is doing this
well i really do let's say i play rookie
one here okay
so it's not that i want to play rook
takes e5 in truth what i really want to
do is i want to play rook on e1 to e2
and make a king march to the queen side
that's nice so let's say you play rook
g8 right
this kind of a situation like what else
are you supposed to do with black by the
this queen and rook ending is horrible
he could take rook takes e5
and laugh at you yeah because the
difference between the other one is our
king is so
safe right right in comparison for sure
no and your king is terrible and you're
up upon in that position a protected
d-pawn that's completely lost
so queen g6 by magnus not giving you the
e-pawn that would be
just horrible right
and here what i want to do is i want to
play rookie 2 so that my g2 pawn is
defended
uh i really taking out all the sting
that might be associated with my e5
e4 break he's defended the pawn a
different way with queen
h3 and i think fabi
is about to make a run to the king side
and if this rook ever strays your move
rook takes e5 maurice
that will be very powerful that'll be
automatic
absolutely the whole position will
collapse fobby with 329 magnus with 122.
fabi didn't win the last game but if he
doesn't win this one he'll be completely
demoralized
he'll just just say forget it i'm not
beating this guy you must win this game
magnus give him credit he found a way to
at least keep the game going with this
exchange sack his bishop on d6 is
extraordinarily
annoying at the moment but at least he
keeps the game
going and we'll see whether or not
fabi can find something he's not playing
the move king h1 fabric keeps playing
waiting moves waiting moves waiting
moves go ahead magnus what do you plan
to do
do you really want to play a4 the answer
is no i'll take that pawn
i'm taking it just take it off the board
you can't go
over to that side because we're going to
take your e5 pawn with a rook
and we're back we're all over you so
that pawn
is not going anywhere so magnus needs a
move and he's under a minute
and he needs to find a move
quickly here i think it would be just a
good idea just to temporarily
move back and forth between d6 and c7
the problem is
any active play by magnus will likely
rebound you mentioned the move a4 as
simply being
bad maurice because you take it and you
use the a pawn as a decoy
a2 a3 okay that
is a move i must confess i myself would
i be
very very resistant to playing such a
move because i just feel like
there's no reason to give my opponent a
weakness that they
might be able to exploit
between i don't think fabi sees the out
yet
he's just got his pieces where he wants
them
but i don't think he sees the win he's
he's looking around
for something and magnus keeps finding
moves keeps staying there he knows he's
got the edge on the clock
he can he can keep playing like a cat
with a mouse
i'm just gonna keep playing moves and
and seeing what's next what's next
and actually forget about the whole cat
and mouse deal
b4 has landed on the board i was about
to say that i thought that
the only reason you play a move like a3
which
i feel is the wrong move but if you're
going to play
a3 you're playing for b4 and uh
b4 it's appeared and it's probably a
very good move because the idea was
any captures that allowed c5 and rook
takes e5 were winning
for fabi and yeah pretty
a takes b4 and your point is that bishop
before we're allowed rookie five
right and eight allows c5 and rookie
five
yeah i think you i think we're about to
see c5 now
winning the e pawn crashing in on the
position
and he has played it here it is
everything for this moment
look at that king on h1 f4 now thrown in
there
it doesn't matter if we play rookie four
bishop c5 rookie five it's the same deal
he does get the e the e3 square for his
bishop
and so maybe that's what he was thinking
that he's able to get this square
but the pawn does block the diagonal so
the king will be safe on h2
wait a minute okay bishop is on c5 oh
you'll be able to put a rook back when
you want against all checks
taking on d6 first what about that move
how does that turn out
takes on e3 and queen d8 rook g8 it
looks like black's hanging on there
no you don't want to you probably don't
want to do this
no not unless there's a clean win yeah
no we don't want to do this
just chill just chill rook up and now
why can't you just take on e5 he's done
so yep that's what we got
bishop three three on the board
with only 40 seconds bobby with with
uh 20 with two minutes there's no queen
b1 danger because
of rookie one so right this looks
just just looks crushing we're being
told rook e6 is the most precise move
and fabian has put it on the board he is
ignoring all counter play there's no
real attack
he can always play rookie eight and
trade off brooks when he needs to queen
f6 will happen as well
there's a desperate queen to be one rook
back to e1
and now amazing to avoid to avoid uh
queen d8 and queen coming back to f6
checkmate alert though everybody there
is a mate threat there is a mate threat
he needs to deal with that he's got one
okay well we could play rookie eight and
then
yeah just trade rooks and that takes
care of that and then then your threats
your threats evaporate there goes the
d-pawn
yeah we just start pushing the d-pad
maybe take the age pawn along for the
ride
his only worry is something something
like a
no he's playing the check there there is
no main worry he just needs to
to realize this position is just winning
you're not going to
you're not going to harass his worship
baby he should check
check played and maybe there was a
bishop f2 possibility in the position so
he's removing his queen from that
arena check again and now king g6
and what is he going to do now is he
worried about is there any
counter player can we just push our pawn
to d6
queen which are queen gone there is
counter play
yeah yeah because we you you can play
queen f2 which threatens to work on e1
and
potentially queen eight three guys sorry
i've always got queen h3 after queen f2
i can move my rook
i like your d6 jen uh what happened
after queen d7 chef you've got a lot of
moves
let's stay on this board guys let's stay
on the main board let's just have this
because it's going quickly
and now d6 on the board
and what does magnus do queen f2 does
what
doesn't threaten anything other than the
rook but where do we put our roof
b1 b1 and if queen c
2 i'd like to trade queens
queenie for check oh sorry i can't go
there you're right
you need for check but
just play rook b1 so if you try to
attack the rook
there's a queen e4 check that clears the
cobwebs
he's got 120 he's played it
and now b2 he's trying to play queen c1
but that doesn't do anything just
promote
queen c1 is answered by queen d1 that's
all fob he has to see
promote to a queen queen c1 check is
answered by queen d1
and that's game and he has done it and
he has won bobby with a comeback
that's why um what a game and a tip from
his evian
as he has tied up the score and once
again
just as we came into the day guys we
have not only have a tied match but we
also have
split tie break so if this match
continues
with a hit and a hit back we might end
up seeing a little
of let's play off but let's set it up
guys we've got
a pre-clutch game and this pre-clutch
game
is as crucial as the clutch game this is
the most important game
it's huge this is the most important
game it gives you armageddon odds
if you are the victor you cannot lose
this game
you cannot afford to lose this game it's
a weird situation where the pre-clutch
game is worth just as much as the clutch
game
actually the tie break odds yep yeah
actually it's kind of funny
if if this game ends in a draw then the
clutch games turn into normal games
they don't even the score the funny
scoring doesn't matter if this
game ends in a draw suddenly it's about
not losing anymore in the la
one of the last two games so we are
seeing here the tie break
nine and a half wins it that's not a
number i think they can get anymore
because uh the three points will
leapfrog anything
i don't think nine and a half is
possible as the as the winning score
what is the score right now exactly
even i know i know it's even but what's
the i've been a half i think they
started the day at 4-4
so i believe after all it is five and a
half so it is so nine and a half is
still possible i'm wrong if you win this
game and you win a clutch game
you do get nine and a half yeah and you
lose the other one
right but that would yeah that would
also just clinch it for you
if somebody wins um game 10 then
they they clinch with any victory right
right game 10 is huge
now i mean all these games have been
huge but now game 10 is
is truly you know you love it when the
match gets
more and more tense the games take on
more and more importance
if game 10 is decisive we know that's
huge for the match
if game 10 is a draw suddenly game 11
becomes
huge right like if game 11 is a draw
then it's 12 so it just is getting
bigger and bigger
it's mattering more and more and more
what a game they they just played magnus
stole two games in a row
didn't look good after that first game
he just steamrolled fabi
but the last two games he blundered in
one and allowed that trick on
on a2 and now this one
he just he wasn't in it from the opening
he was struggling
all the way and fabi just dominated
made another comeback that's three
comebacks in the same match
wow you know you know those games in the
you love when you you're watching a
basketball game it's
you know it's like the nba finals and
one team goes ahead and then the other
team goes ahead
then then they go the switch ties and
you say the lead changes
and how many ties right we're not seeing
lead changes but we're seeing the ties
how many times have they tied up in this
match they started at 0-0
magnus win plus one fobby ties magnus
goes plus one again
fabi ties magnus does it again bobby
ties again
i mean this is what you live for but you
never see this happen
how often does this ever happen in chess
it's very rare because there's so many
draws in chess so
the the punching and punching back and
all in order
it's also weird because there is that
momentum effect in chess that usually
when somebody's hit they feel a little
down
especially in blitz and rapid so
incredibly rare
i have to say i i call the match it was
from a world cup between lavon and
aronian and mdl two of the players
actually played in this clutch chess
knockout matches
and i think that was like a semi-final
from a world cup
and guys it went into overtime and
double overtime
armageddon and there was a rook got
blundered
and at the end of that match
i was exhausted you didn't even play
crawled into bed it was that bad it was
amazing
uh amazing match but i know exactly what
you mean maurice triple overtime nba
final and here we have it our pre-clutch
game
is as we've done the math just as
important as a clutch game
um we see magnus starting with one night
at three
wow and hey welcome to our 24 000
viewers from all over the world
if you're new we welcome you new to
chats
or a long time fabio magnus fan
um welcome you're in for a good final
ride here
the move has been played on the board i
thought i saw it okay oh sorry i was
mistaken it was probably
me uh channeling yasser because of
course knight of three is a movement
yasser would approve of right or
not oh
c4 first right why do you like c4 better
than knight f3
i do why because i like
i like that after c4 e5 i like to play
white and a lot of people who play
knight f3
are trying to play c4 but they don't
want to see
e5 isn't it as a response
so for me i don't have that problem i
like playing the black
i like playing the sicilian tempo ahead
and this is the first when you wait when
you wait with knight f3 then you also
have some extra options
once in a while to like to play same-ish
variations and stuff like that maybe
if it transposes okay so there's more
options
that last game that last game was the
very first game as we see a petrov
on the board and now knight c4 petrov
different
than your typical petrov line
this was the very first game that last
game we just saw is the very first
game that magnus that
fabi outplayed magnus from start
to finish and won start to finish
the two wins he had before were not of
that type
this last game was exactly that two
in a row i mean i mean one game where he
said i'm starting from the starting
position
i get a better position i outplay you i
crush you magnus had done that to him a
couple of times
that was the first time that fabi did
that is fabi getting stronger
we'll see well guys i just wanted to say
sorry that uh
we have a very very exciting game and
i'm not
i i believe they played this line before
but i don't think it was from
london i think it might have been from a
sinkhole cup
certainly a grand chess tour event but
check this out i mean
we've had a queen trade but not in a
very conventional way
it was the knights that have been
capturing the queens
and in this position magnus didn't just
recapture capture and probably make a
very very
tame draw he said you want my bishop go
ahead and have it
you can take the bishop knight takes but
i will play
knight take c7 forking the king and the
rook
and look at them apples how do you like
that move
see mags just recoiled
why did magnus recoil is he look at me
shaking his head
well let's understand this move is he
trying to say that after knight c7 check
king d8 knight a8 knight c1 my knight is
getting out but yours is not
um i'm let's let's take a look yes
because the material right now black is
straight down in exchange right so if
both of our knights get trapped
that would be very good for white i
don't understand how does black's night
get out at all
so that's what i'm saying that's why we
don't understand fabi's conception yet
fabi's move just looks like a horrible
mistake
because yeah if we both lose our our
nights then um
like i said white's up in exchange right
yes
so um okay okay
guys i'm sorry i'm not the opening
expert amongst us
i'm going to have to ask
bar for revolution for some serious help
here
uh c6 is that known var i mean
wow where did that come from and magnus
didn't go for it he just said
i'm going to avoid any of fabi's
preparation
and just play takes and bring my knight
out
and play a better end game position and
he uh
you know whether fabi was bluffing or
not um
your rook wasn't taken
that is incredible we're being told c6
was a novelty
was it a novelty or a blunder
that move looked looked suspicious
but did not want to go down that route
obviously fabi could have played
differently fabi did not have to give
away
the piece that easily that they
exchanged that easily he could have
played his knight back to d4
so magnus shook his head thought about
it and said
um there's a fobby bluffing there's a
fobby prep in there
let me get out of there and just take
what looks like a better position
technically
i think i can i can worm him over
in this kind of position that was
bizarre that was absolutely
bizarre there must have been something
there like that they
that he at least saw even if it wasn't
um legit with uh intense analysis
but because i did see the analysis bar
liked
magnus's position a lot if we took on
c78
but this position does look pretty
comfortable for white yes i mean we're
no question um we've just got a
beautiful squares and you know maurice
likes to rave about doubled pawns when
they open files but these aren't just
doubled pawns
these are double isolated pawns and
those are a little harder to defend
i don't mind double isolated pawns i
don't mind double isolated pawns i'm
that's the same pawns to me files do
open
but they need to open to somewhere
these these files are opening to nowhere
i'm not i'm not impressed by
the e file for black or the c file for
black
i'm much more impressed by white's
simple pressure that he's going to apply
to this position castle you're king
bring your bishop out
your knight has a d4 square what's not
to like
white is just better that said is white
more better here than he was than taking
the rook on a8
i don't know if you got the rook
i'll take the rook i hear you yes sir
it's a rook on a8 this this is something
you'd say
yeah white's better but why could i have
something
else more concrete apparently a novelty
is that of euphemism guys
that is
all those amateurs out there playing
chess for the first time you know
playing like
a4 or and rook a3 we just got to say no
that's not a bad move it's just a
novelty that's right
you could play a lot of novelties in
chess if that's a novelty
man i can make up a lot of new moves
easily
easily you threaten my piece i ignored
oh
novelty i remember i was
i was in st louis we were at the world
chess hall of fame it was burning boards
and i was playing against uh shannon
shannon's husband i was playing there
was my opponent and next to me was
magnus carlson
and magnus opened with his candle
h2h4 these are lit candles by the way so
we were playing something called burning
boards an art exhibition by glenn kino
and uh magnus you know great athlete
wonderful chess player
apparently not that fond of fire um you
know i had a
healthy respect for the flames let's put
it that way
so wanted to make moves that were closer
to um
closer to his um his body so that he
wasn't reaching over across the board
right but h4 is definitely not a novelty
by the way
h4 is not a novelty we a lot of amateurs
say i've done that many many times
what are you talking about absolutely
this has been seen before
we'd have to we'd have to go a ways
maybe h4 b5 or something to
to start getting into new land now this
position on the board
that was weird considered very
comfortable for white
this is not as comfortable anymore no i
could have made something out
now the open files now we can talk about
my my open files when you double pawns
especially that part on c2 why is it
sitting there weak you can bring a rook
to c8
drop your knight back and go after the
pawn on c2
you can have my d-pawn if you're gonna
let me weaken your
seat if you get me get your c pawn and
weaken your d-pawn
exactly although i might go ahead i was
gonna say i see it in the following way
that white wants to play bishop b2
and put pressure on the spawn and bishop
b2 and castle's
queen side to defend upon on c2 but
there's a tactic in the position that
might
be a little bit detrimental there's a
move like
bishop um pardon me bishop f5
the idea being that if bishop b2 well
whoop i can
capture on d3 trying to fork
king and bishop here something like this
is what's going through my mind as a
possibility for black
i like what you're saying i mean knight
b5
to c3 to e2 played very quickly by
magnus i thought he had
made a lot of sense you just go after
the weakness he has played your move
bishop to f5
preventing the possibility of this move
uh takes on i mean bishop to b2
and king d1
what he's now insisting that he's going
to achieve
but bishop b2 wait okay there is
a tempo there is a tempo for
knight i thought bishop b296 96 looks to
cover everything
right so right so so my only problem is
my pawn on b7
so if i stop if i defend my pawn on b7
i'm assuming it is it is something i
have to defend
then don't i get to play knight e6
anytime you play bishop
to b2 that is that is what i would think
okay so the question is but the question
is how you would like to defend the pawn
on b7
yeah because i don't want to play king
c7 that just seems so boring
yeah if i play rook beat rook b8 wow
and he's played rogue b8 this i think
he's added it up the same way
bishop b2 and now knight back to e6 and
this is what i was saying
now that's defended now he can push his
pawn to b6
what's actually happening here white's
king
no he's magnus is playing uh after your
own heart
yes he just played bishop d5 saying i've
won the pawn on d4
everything he's doing is about this pawn
on d4 i just want to be up a pawn
this is remarkable we're we're gonna
have to give
uh magnus uh gold card status
in the palm grubber's society club
i mean that's impressive i mean you got
to applaud the effort
a6 as baby says why do you put the pawn
on b6
what what is the point of this move i
what is like what is the point this is
way out there rookie
you're gonna have to subscribe to the st
louis chess club channel to get the
answer to the
question and by the way he did not
capture
the pawn yet he says i'm going to get it
whenever i want h5
bobby says you can have it whenever you
like i'm willing to go down this route
with you
wow this is this is so remarkable this
is clearly
a pawn that can be captured
but if you take with a knight
you will be pinned along the diagonal
you could take with a bishop
well let's give it a let's show the
viewers
what we're chewing mauling over we're
going to take the night
so that the night which was defending
the pawn is
disappeared we're assuming that fabby
would like to recapture with the pawns
to keep some cohesion
in his pawn structure we're thinking
that well
we snagged upon bishop takes pawn and
fabi would likely want to keep his two
bishops and maybe we could
park our bishop on b6 be careful by the
way
just for sneaking i'm stinking a view of
the live
board and i see that that after rookie
one
h5 a4 so the same ideas that we've been
looking at
maybe um
magnus wants to play a5 and cement his
control over the b6 square
a5 h4 what is going on
i'm trying to use trying to exploit
there's only one thing that magnus has
to be concerned about
is the position of his king it's not
easy for him to coordinate his rooks
so magnus has this very coordinated
position
white does with everything after this d4
pawn
however this king on d1 does
prevent the coordination of the rook so
if you ever play king d2
bishop g5 check drives you right back
into your cubby hole
so magnus is trying to improve his
position as much as possible
and then at the appointed time since you
cannot prevent it
capture on e6 it looks like fabi's
saying please capture
soon because i want to get my play going
even though i'm down a pawn so fabi's
willing to take the two bishops
pawn down and play this position with
space and potential dynamism
very interesting position to evaluate
and by the way they're both at the five
minute mark
and a5 on the board let's see a concrete
variation uh maurice we want to play a5
the idea behind
i think what magnus is doing is first of
all to
give his rook an extra scope for his
rook
and cement the bishop on b6 for example
the variation i'm
thinking about is rook h5 bishop e6
takes
takes on d4 i'm anticipated e5 that was
why
i think magnus put his his pawn on a5 so
that his bishop
would be protected once it arrives on
this square
now is this compensation this is the
point this is what he went for and he's
played it
he's just playing freely and actively
and magnus has backed down
magnus has said i don't want to go for
that i'm just going to play bishop back
to f3
you can keep your pawn for now i don't
believe this is going to change
much in the position and fabinho
c5 which which is a very nice file
and by the way another rook can go to c8
a little bit later
although at the moment it's not possible
so you might have to pay attention to 85
maybe tr trade off the the light squared
bishop and then we can play rook c8 so
that we're not points
you don't have to keep an eye on that b7
pawn anymore
yeah but but rook a4 does hunt down
this uh pawn on d4 again
this pawn has been on both players minds
for quite some time
and magnus is just preparing everything
before he takes it
so we're going for the hot potato that
nobody wants
but yeah we're gay foreign is hanging
so you can't just take everybody right
if we trade off we trade off your
bishops
you can't just make a full-scale trade
because we're going to play rook takes
a5
so we're not there yet but wait isn't h4
hanging also as well though at the end
yes so yes is that's a good point my
h-pawn is hanging so take
take ding he's played rook a4
okay so magnus thus far is playing still
quite consequently i mean he is he does
want to capture this pawn and
maybe even there's another possibility
of playing bishop g4
along with look at this he's sacrificing
the b7 pawn he played
rook c8 not the b7 pawn the a6 pawn
bishop b7 rook c7 bishop takes a6
that's the most important factor because
you're playing rook takes on c2
and what's up with this line
because this counter play though i mean
this bishop
unfortunately it's an i mean this is a
this is a choo-choo train that's that's
huge
but that bishop on b2 gives play
i don't know guys i don't i don't i
wouldn't feel comfortable as white
allowing the rook to come to c2 no
kidding on the other hand
rook to c4 what's the story with
your apon what about your apon what's
what's that about the rook still gets
play
uh you could take on b7 but i mean he
can just trade off and put his work on
a2
and you have to watch out do you have a
king c1
knight c5 i mean there's play for black
and
it's weird it is it is very weird indeed
and magnus sees this and magnus is
thinking
deeply about the position he's down to
332
as fabi is playing freestyle chess right
now activity
play not necessarily so bishop takes d4
has been played allowing a mass trade on
the d4 square
and then rook c2 what's this there is a
check
there is a check on careful alert alert
i see
my spidey sense tingling about bishop g4
check
so if you do go for this massive trade
you mentioned
maurice okay but check is at five
f5 sorry turning the tables dope
turning the tables this this move by
magnus finally capturing the pawn
may give his opponent just what he needs
knight takes on d4 knight takes bishop
takes there's no check
you can it seems that you can just do a
mass trade
and then take on c2 and you're back
you're just in business
is this game gonna now be drawn and
we'll be down to the two clutch games
wow i mean i'm not actually i'm not even
sure
what is what is really going oh you
can't even take the b7 pawn at the end
because of rook c1
rook c2 give me your work on e1 no no no
that's not true so let me take a pawn
you know me check king
oh you don't check on c2 i thought
i had this beautiful little king f1 uh
you know hiding uh hold the height in
but uh
rook e8
sorry okay lots of calculations by fabi
and he has gone into this line we're
seeing it play out will he take on c2 or
a5
not much to think about there he did
take on c2
and he just judged it finally there's no
b7 pawn hanging
frabi now just leaned back and kind of
stretched and said go
make a move i'm not worried about this
position i should be
okay here you have the b7 pawn he might
get the a5 pawn this looks like plenty
of activity guys
oh yeah no no question that uh
the double pawns in the center
fabby has f i thought that they were
very weak i thought that magnus was
going to get a
a beautiful magnus carlson kind of grind
that he's so famous for i mean he beats
everybody when he gets
you know his grippers on the position
but
somehow his body language sorry as his
body language you were talking about it
magnus just put his hand up in
frustration
you saw that and then he shook his head
and then his face
and then his just his face kind of uh
i thought i had something and i got
nothing and now he just played rook c4
which doesn't look like the kind of move
you absolutely want to play by the way
now
f2 is hanging uh d3 is hanging
i mean it seems like one of those lines
have to work
well he's going to capture something as
fabby it just doesn't know
uh which way which one to capture
i'd start with this and let's just have
a look see how this
might go because this captured on d3
right away okay yes rook c8
rook c8 rook to rook
wait is white down upon white is
currently
down a pawn at the moment hoping to get
b7
hoping to get b7 back at some point but
is he going to
yeah yes it looks like black
yes but he's not going to get a6
that's at least that's real
if you play bishop for example bishop to
b5
right right he gets b7
and then i don't know just move right
just any more
i don't like white i don't like black's
pawn structure though that's the only
thing i'm not feeling in this position
he checked king d2 bishop back to f5
and now fabi's saying i will get rook c2
and take on f2
i don't really i don't want that f2 pawn
i don't want you to get a six
what's the deal here well
we can come back so rook c2 check yeah
king d1 this game just
took off i mean like just went on fire
because you can get passers he can get
passers
what is happening right so you're saying
rook f2 bishop a6 we
also take g2 and rook g3 is in the
offing but
you're a pawn fast and speaking of fast
magnus has been the faster one in this
game and that could be a key factor as
he did not take on f2 instead he
retreated with work c5 thinking
you take my a pawn i take yours um
what's up with
b4 we just have b5 it looks like
and then work b5 and then but
i like white little worried about that
we're talking about it
rook a3 on the board yeah i'd like to
play
i got a choo-choo train here guys yeah i
know right
that is it is a little scary there for
um bobby
i wouldn't i i get it you know you can't
calculate all that
so you know he determined that he has
better chances here but
but he's the black king
is the black king getting to a7 and then
challenging whatever that a pawn
does so thanks just played king c7 here
okay
oh he's played bishop here i thought
that was a dangerous move because of
bishop e2
the idea is go ahead and take the pawn
but you may
you may regret it instead of that but h3
is picking two but you're going real
fast aren't you
that was the intent but at the end of
the day maybe i can reroute my bishop to
like d5 and sacrifice my bishop anyway
it didn't happen because
he played f3 f3 bishop a8 were played
right on the board king i don't know
fabi looked good before but giving up
this b and a pawn
why give the guy this kind of chance
yeah scary
that just seemed that just seemed very
suspect but king c2 maybe now you can
get your king over to a7
like just yeah but for me this is an
eternal advantage for
white the bishop will go for example
i don't know to e2 apart my pawn on
a6 and even if you put your king over
here
on a7 you know you get that great
blockade whatever whatever
this rook will one day just menace uh
the kingside bonds with rook e1
and e5 by bobby five that looks like
i mean every movement it's a very
dangerous move i
i mean we we spoke about it a lot you
don't
really want to put your pawns on the
same color as your bishop
you can just imagine in your mind's eye
if whites
ever gets his king to d4 the bishop on
a8 will be dead you know what we're
seeing here
is time pressure starting to count as
well because fabi's down to 37 seconds
and his instinctive moves
are not helping him his work looks bad
on f3 now he's played
g5 i'm not sure what he's hoping for
over there right now but it looks like
white has been able to make preparation
moves
progress now rook rook to beat
three that does a lot of the fabric yeah
that doesn't allow the black work to get
behind the pawn i would i would go for
that if i were black
but he's just ignored and played f5 and
allowed
a rook to go to b4 and trap the rook
jesus played terribly in this end game
and magnus now
with a chance to play the move rook b4
and it's on the board
and that's right it is awful and that is
the end of the game because of that
outside past pawn that's something we've
seen in numerous clutch games
how could he let this happen that was
terrible
you're going to be distracted to the
defense of the apon and then my king is
going to creep up and win
all of the black bombs this is terrible
guys because the king will go here
that's a
completely easy easy easy winning
uh bishop ending um
oh he's magnificent and said this
position is just as good his king
is just so superior right now the d5
pawn is dead
bishop e6 takes on d5 resigns this is
over
somehow from what was an even position
fabi played so well
and then just played horribly in time
pressure and will go
down a point we will not see a tie
breaker bobby will have to win one of
the clutch games
in order to stay in this match in fact
if he wins he
he jumps and takes a lead with three
points
there's still a lot of pressure but fabi
went down
in what is just a bad game on his side
and by the way they have drawn zero
games
so far we're assuming this will be a win
that's it f4 and fabi can just resign
there's no hope here
actually there's one hope against hope
land your king on g7 and play bishop
takes
f pawn good luck with that
absolutely good luck but magnus said
king f6
never going to happen i see that hope
not going to happen and fabi resigns in
that moment magnus takes the lead again
oh that was a terribly played end game
by fabi i mean i i hear what you're
saying maurice uh
the ticking clock uh makes uh fools of
us
all but i really didn't think that he
had to go down
in this ending right back over here i
hear what you were saying
right here after the move rook takes c2
i thought that this was
even steven i really did definitely and
after rook c4 uh there's no way i'm
letting you get
both this pawn and there's no way and
after
the move bishop d3 which happened
rook here i like what you said right
here oops excuse me you said
hey man just don't lose the a6 pawn you
can
you can lose the no but i'm sorry in
that moment he can't play it because of
bishop g4
you know how funny is that that was the
that was the skewer i wanted a long time
ago remember
well you know yes maurice likes the
expression
one win is worth two and i think bobby's
been very good at hitting back but in
this case it's not about psychology
actually
just literally numerically that win is
worth too
because now there are three point games
right so just having the edge is
everything huge
and and by the way there was a draw
there was a drawing game too i was
mistaken
they had one draw but three decisive
games so far and look at this
right we couldn't have a better setup
because
everything will be decisive decided now
in the next two games a win is worth
three a draw one and a half
13 grand per game
and this is the thing though 13 grand
per game
the clutch title on the line fabiano's
been playing some great chess so don't
count him out
he's gonna try to hit back as he's been
want to do in this match
but i gotta say this game is leaving us
with one of the biggest mysteries of
clutch chess so far
because at a c6 move i mean we were
shocked similarly with f3 right isn't it
funny they're mirror images of
each other fabiano played f3 in that
game allowing queen h4 check just
winning the exchange
yep and now in this one though even more
shocking
c6 allowing knight c7 but our producers
have
made a very nice video of fabi
as a clutch player i'm sure you're going
to enjoy this on the break guys
i think we already saw it yeah we're
just going to take a quick break
[Music]
since 2009 our mission has always been
to teach and promote the value chess
brings to our community
in these times of social distancing it's
more important than ever
that we stay connected to carry on that
mission we are currently offering 24
weekly classes online through our
youtube
and twitch channels we're also holding
tournaments and private lessons online
from the comfort of their own home
students can enjoy all the benefits of
our scholastic chess initiative
digitally
our scholastic outreach continues with
virtual chess classrooms
scholastic tournaments and scouts bsa
merit badge workshops
on behalf of everyone at the saint louis
chess club we hope you and your loved
ones stay safe and continue to watch
play and enjoy the game of chess
be surprised be intrigued
be delighted the world chess hall of
fame in st
louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love
three galleries highlight the history
culture and creativity behind
the game explore chess in ways you never
imagined
it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class
art play together the world chess hall
of fame
mind art experience
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
clutch chess and we are
in the clutch of the clutch of the
clutch guys as
we've got big money at stake but it's
also about this title the international
clutch chest title magnus vs bobby
now we're going to three-point games
that means fabi wins he grabs a lead
straight from underneath magnus whereas
it's also sudden death for fabi because
magnus wins he wins the match that's it
that's it
here huh there's going to be no playoffs
there will be no more games these are
the last two games
of this competition for sure as it's
clear what has to happen
this is what you want to be one of the
situation you want to be in
is magnus he's up one and he knows
if he loses this game he still has a
chance but he's not of the mindset
of losing this game you can best believe
he's thinking
let me win this game and close this
match out
pressure is on we have not seen both of
them playing well
in this on this day yesterday i could
say
you saw more more quality the pressure
is on right now you can see it you can
feel it
and it has been ratcheted up because now
three points that just leap frogs magnus
if fabi gets it ends it for fabi if
magnus gets it
i can't imagine right now the tension
that they're feeling i mean
for the match winner 35
000 runner up 13 000 for the next game
for this game and the next gen this is
what we had hoped for
uh when making this event and this is
what all the viewers are hoping for
and by the way let's let's get into the
predictions of this opening i mentioned
it earlier yes i don't think that magnus
is going to repeat the sicilian i think
he's going to do
double king pawn um and you know two
draws
it's a win right two draws gives this
man the title
i know it doesn't give him as much
clutch money but i think his number one
priority is to win the match
i'll agreed agree that's there but good
luck with with making the two draws
happen easily as fabi is going to fight
to the death
in this game no question about it fabi
has come back before we saw him do it
against wesley
we've seen him do it three times against
magnus in this match alone
and we're off and i was wrong you were
wrong jen here he goes
and the same line that game so much gave
so much success
to fabi and now
we're seeing wow look at them go just
fly to this position
look at them go and he did not castle as
he did the last game
last game he castle the knight h4 landed
on the board knight g6 the improvement
to stop
this knight h knight h4 idea
so that was the novelty for magnus to
play knight g6 and now knight d2
and that allows magnus to just play
bishop back to e7 and play d6
and all square it just looks like a
normal position
no problems here bishop now going to b3
well we always have fun with these games
guys because they're so rich
game 10 a position that's this complex
at some point things open up
and that's when we as commentators and
spectators really start having fun
they either open up because somebody
plays g4 or d5 or because
black even gets in f5 at some point but
this one bishop has gone to d5
pinning that knight on c6 so it looks
like bishop
dc what do you think bishop d7 or b7
queen c7 queen c7 nine of the above none
of the queen queenie a quick a4 look at
look at fabi come forward
wondering about this move both of them
over 10 minutes using only their
increment
so far but finally fabi started to think
and looking at his clock
and for the first time under and he's
playing d4
i like it this is a very
straightforward aggressive potentially
too aggressive because you could be
liquidating in the middle of the board
a4 was a bit more on the cagey side
d4 now saying i've got a pin on your
knight on c6
i'm trying to take advantage of it but i
like the spirit of the move is queen e8
looks like a move that's more suited to
a closed position right
you're putting the queen on a
potentially open file and it's blocking
the development of the work on f8 so for
people watching
who are just starting to learn about the
opening principles people make
weird moves and closed positions a lot
of times it's a sign
open it up but jen i got to tell you d4
to me
it's one of those moves that if you
liquidate too quickly
you might find yourself in just an equal
position which you don't want
in the terms exactly i i feel
when you are you need to take your
opportunity when it comes
so d4 has to say i believe queen 8 is
actually a bad move
and d4 gets the job done if it's not
getting the job done
then you don't play moves like this
because it just gives the guy too
easy play let me trade everything off in
the center boom and you know we're good
to go
now this move though magnus has been
sitting for a while
and exactly you know what if magnus is
thinking for a while and it doesn't
liquidate
easily then kudos to this move look at
magnus he actually just looked like he
swore at himself he is not happy
with this move maybe maybe it's
great for him then great for uh for
white that would be
awesome if that is the case as magnus
has burned a minute and a half
so far and he's going through gyrations
right now uh his eyes are
wide open so those eyebrows are up boys
yeah but usually he's a little bit more
relaxed but he's leaning in guys as he's
played the move work to be eight which
by the way he discourages
the analysis board is on the right the
light board's on yeah
of course yeah i just i just my eyes
were just playing jerks on me sorry
um i was just thinking that if i'm in
black
shoes while you're talking there i
wanted just to get out of the pin
and say okay you've got a move d4
you know the e5 pawn's well defended
what's the follow-up to d4 he just took
with the e pawn
talk about forever changing the pawn
structure making it
very dynamic indeed he takes on d4 we've
we've got
a very uneven structure now before
obviously no pawn traits so pretty much
everything was
similar except for the placement of the
pawns
now we have true asymmetry e takes on d4
and you can see that black has this
construction with four pawns on the
queen side
white the same with center pawns as well
this pawn on d4 will be traded off and
black
will well maybe maybe maybe it will be
traded off
there's going to be pressure on the c
pawn but if black does trade on d4
then he'll be left with this isolated
pawn isolated and backward pawn
on the d6 square and rook to b8
so magnus got out of the pin uh it took
a lot of time
for both takes on d4 rook v8 i would
have
left the tension in the center
personally but he is eyeballing
knight b4 chasing this bishop away
and then maybe later playing c5 c4
so now
to deliver the goods maybe you just
chill with the move a2 a3 i'm not quite
sure what
the follow-up should be
that makes a lot of sense this knight
before idea coming straight out of the
zaitsev
a variation of the real lopez very
typical you aim for the d3 square we saw
karpov do it a lot in the world
championship match
against kasparov this
is a threat your bishop is going to get
caged he's going to play c4
you don't want to give up your light
square bishop not not in this
circumstance
the really funny part is uh
normally in a kind of a
rui lopez where you do have your rook on
v8 this knight
actually ends is usually on f6 so that
you could harass
the rook with the move bishop f4 it's
kind of ironic
that the knight happens to just so
happens to be on
g6 so you don't have to move uh
bishop f4 harassing the rook anymore so
it's
kind of nice okay rook c1 pressuring the
pawn and look at this sacrificing the
pawn is magnus
knight before going for the idea and
fabi is going straight down the path
he will have an extra pawn but these
pawns are notoriously difficult
to defend meaning the pawn on d5 that's
what i'm talking about
if you were to capture on c5
now which is what because there's no
knight d3 yet because of bishop e7
you could take on d5 and play this
position
is this pawn on d5 going to get massive
protection
because everybody's going to attack it
bishop on b7 knight on f4
rook on d8 i mean everybody's going to
gang up on it and
at the moment your knight on d2 leaves a
poor impression
trying to save this pawn okay so
i i started with bishop c5 maurice uh
fabi seems to be awkwardly gawking
at that pawn but he hasn't captured it
yet so
how would the line go bishop takes c5
you just did it knight takes defense i
did okay so you
you kind of like it but be careful
because i do have the thread of d6 in
this exact position
played moves have been played so why
can't i
and he's done it knight takes d5 pawn
takes bishop takes c5
rook takes bishop to b7
good so far how do you defend the d-pawn
right i i was just wondering about the
the execution of the
uh uh of the captures because
if he if he didn't do it with the when
the bishops were on the board
there was this move d6 yeah that's right
d6 is coming no we don't want this to
happen right it's cemented so so that's
why yes so that's why
rook c5 um bishop b7 knight
b3 we're all played okay so we're up to
date with the players cool so the moment
the pawn is defended twice and you
would have to hope that you could get
multiple attackers
on this pawn somehow now rook d8 makes
sense
queen d7 knight f4 will happen
eventually what about night a5
knight c6 um
[Music]
that night trying to block the square
but i think the problem is you might be
able to since i'm pinned you might be
able to take and like play knight f4
right yep and queen e4 and it's
gonna be hard for me to keep defending
it especially with the monster knight on
f4
i'm not liking this i'm not liking this
rook d8 so if you play rookie
bishop back in this position that you're
analyzing because you're back
probably take it
rook takes now my a pawn is hanging
so if i get your d-pawn you get my a
pawn
what's this evaluation
i don't know reasonable compensation i
would think i see a lot of
active black pieces uh queen's ready to
jump down to e2 maybe to e4
start spreading some some fun some
funsies knight h3 check right
yes breaking into your position
so magnus has been deep in thought
though trying to work
out this position as
his time is now down to five minutes
on the clock fabi with eight minutes is
a huge game if
magnus draws this game which it looks
like that's the max he should get out of
this position
because he's down a pawn and fabi's
perfectly fine everywhere else
so the max magnus should get is a draw
if he does that
then fabi is forced to win with the
black pieces in the next game
exactly and good luck with that as well
now we've seen him do it we've seen him
do it doesn't mean he can't
and magnus is of the type that he
doesn't like to just make draws
but no but it would be interesting to
see him play that game by the way this
is a thirteen thousand dollar game
if this game is drawn the next game will
be for the title
and twenty six thousand dollars if you
win the game
twenty six thousand dollars
swing in terms of 50k to 35
that's right you would get 50 and a 26
000
pot as well so 76
000 on one chess game so
this is huge a huge moment magnus is
feeling it magnus has been so
deep in thought though in this position
he is now down to 351
we've been talking and analyzing and
options and magnus has not
moved if i've got eight minutes on the
clock i wanna keep some tension
in the position whatever magnus does
next fabi's gotta spend two minutes and
figure out
how do i keep the position alive because
he
can make mistakes if there's just a
little bit of juice
even if i give him a little bit of
activity that maybe
when i think let me start playing for
something i
you need this game to have some life
that's the key you need the game to have
some life
but magnus now guys he's going under
three minutes
that's a huge uh time differential
five minutes in a ten minute game i mean
what is he doing what is he doing
roof d8 is absolutely suggestive uh
instead queen to d7 instead exactly
all i could all i can imagine is that
he's thinking that
he might prefer
to have the f8 rook coming to d8 and so
he wants to give himself that option but
was it worth the five-minute thing not
only that he has but queen g4 and knight
f4
is also now on the agenda whereas before
we were trying to put our queen on e4
but there it could be a direct mating is
that
queen g4 knight f4 well h3 against queen
i've always said you you you are the
lady for the attack i mean
when i'm upon up i'm thinking that when
that
when i'm upon down i'm thinking you know
like uh look let me win it back
um but what's this we got a very for the
game
99 c6 now you can't play bishop takes
i'm playing playing
pawn takes on c6 all right you're not
getting
this pawn back that easily that's a big
difference because when i had my
when i had my rook on d8 i was you were
forced to take with the rock
which was much less than to say the
leaps so rook to e8
was rather quickly played by magnus
magnus
did not play this correctly that big
thing you know john nunn says long
think wrong think this one here
does this keeps the game alive
what you wanted some sharpness in the
position you can't just attack this pawn
anymore
and probably with 707 to magnus's 253
and i think the world champion is in
trouble
this position there how do you get your
pawn back that easily and you're
pointing out this beautiful move yes
queen d4
centralizing and stopping the queen from
going to g4 stop united f4
that's right so what if i if i try to
insist guys and play like queen f5 with
the idea of knight f4 next
well i was going to say that
you you revealed your hand to me uh
um uh jen that
i knew you wanted to play queen g4 and i
knew you wanted to play knight f4 so i
i purposely played queen d4 to like
annoy you
well it did the trick it did the trick i
mean now
and you still have after bishop c6 pawn
takes c6 because
the knight on f3 guards your queen on b4
correct correct
absolutely right 24 looks awesome but
fabi has now gone into his own deep
think
he's got to move at the six minute mark
as far as i'm concerned
and he has done so with the other knight
to d4 cementing his piece
this does not look as harmonious as
queen d4 but he went to
actually he would have stopped knight a
queen g4 with the other move where is
this knight going this is one of those
superfluous night settings a la
divoretsky
the two knights are sort of protecting
each other
but now the d-pawn looks vulnerable
well i guess maybe there's some
situations where we could play like
queen somewhere and knight f5
but yeah by the way you notice that
magnus has
sped up his play the queen d6
b4 instantly played
picking up a tempo against the rook
presumably aha
i was about to say presumably so that
the knight will be able to go to f4 and
it will be protected by the queen
but now um rookie four
in the position isn't there a knight
f5 knight five queen
queen going somewhere to attack it
i'm trying i'm trying desperately
to play the move d5 d6
if i can get the queen to go back and
well i don't know where
uh i'm trying to play the move d5 d6
yeah i mean of course you are and queen
of three instead
attacking the rook allowing rook to f4
but that square is a square that the
knight wanted so this game is getting oh
he's doubled rooks instead
he's doubled rooks isn't knight f5
possible
what's the deal well that
if uh
i'm getting uh confused by uh what's
going on i
i don't quite understand is there some
trick i'm missing
i want to play well i'm not even sure
what i want trick you missing for who
what do you mean
um
i'm i'm wondering what white is doing
what white
is doing what after knight f5
this is the current position right by
the way look out for a queen c3
bit of trickery as well there's a lot of
threats
magnus now down to 141.
finally 27. this is exactly the position
that fabi wanted to see happen this kind
of
busy crazy it is not
any simple chess anymore that rook
should have been on d8
uh and fabi with 511 magnus at
141 and we are being told knight to b8
is a monster move
[Music]
that's a gorgeous move but the idea that
if ricky ate queen e4
and we're displacing your queen you
don't have any good squares for your
queen
exactly some of them like queen a7 allow
queen e4 rook c8 anyway 97 wow
that's a crazy line guys beautiful
beautiful but uh like
where would you put the queen here
sorry what which line were you saying
was a crazy line jen
well i was thinking about a square where
i could actually play queen e4 here
but um probably this is not the one
because you're queen
c3 queen queen does protect
exactly so this one doesn't quite work
although d6 here is v6 they looked good
57 seconds for magnus and he's played h6
that's not a good sign for him for sure
this position
bobby can feel it win this game take a
lead
and force magnus to win the next one the
this
extra d-pawn is assuring white that he
has the big edge for sure there's no
question about it
so good guys i'm just wondering is
knight v8 still a good move you you'd
have to go
uh it looks really strong uh he's not
fighting knight b8 come on
night they're saying not anymore because
of the back rank you know
so knight v8 knight b8 is crazy talk
nobody
looks at that in a blitz game but but
now that we've heard the move we can't
can't keep our eyes off of it what a
crazy looking move
so instead the much more human h4 has
been played
magnus with 44 seconds that's a very
attractive move as well
absolutely knight e5 is not playable
that's important
if you cannot play knight e5 then queen
e4 hank so what is the deal with h5
right now is the knight going to f8 he's
played king h8 yes
oh wait can his knight go to f4 this is
another little bit of trickery black's
knight
landing on f4 could be something you
have to watch out for
this is uh this is a bit of trickery
that's nasty
knight f4 is weird because it gets the
knight to e2
why couldn't he play the last move why
couldn't he play it on the last move why
did he have to play this move
the king on h8 would have allowed knight
takes h6
check and taken on f4 okay so
he spotted it he he spotted it give him
kudos there to fobby not allowing this
move and he's brought his knight back to
e3
the king has come back but white's
position is
has improved so much a knight on e3
guarding the d-pawn
his rook can come into the game now his
rook on f1
what does black do next and h5 will
happen at any moment
so this is all white
3 47 on the clock to 38 seconds guys
38 seconds and magnus in a lost position
much worse anyway bobby if
pop guys if fabi closes this out he will
catapult to the lead
with a three-point victory and that'll
put the pressure on magnus
and that would mean that uh drawl in the
next match would
give him this clutch chest title it's
got to deliver
this is what clutch chest is all about
this is the clutch game this is your
last white
you win this you leap frog and he's
played rook to c1
i mean he's a knight f8 by magnus
instantly played magnus knew he had to
bring this piece back
but how does white seal the deal what
are the moves
well guys well ever since i heard about
the move knight b8 i can't keep my eyes
off of it because
58 rook c7 right now is it strong again
knight v8 you move mcqueen that i have
rook c7
right but where if rookie three yeah
that's the problem now there's the
rookie three idea now
rookie three though pawnee three rook b8
rook c7 still looks
interesting but yeah maybe not the most
practical
so when you do it when you don't know
what yeah move like a two a3 just
protecting the problem
you know keeping or king g2 action to
keep also but pg2 puts you on that long
diagonal
not really a fan of that move but like
you said a3 he needs a move
he needs two moves that's what he needs
he needs to move he needs to keep moving
forward he's put his knight back on f5
that allows rookie one check
and uh looks like that's not that great
for black
black down to 31 seconds is magnus
magnus has to be mindful
boy this one is going down to the wire
24 seconds this is the pressure fabi
needs to keep on his opponent
20 seconds now for magazines very
strange square
h 7 looking to go
to f6
and jen you're knight b8
you're knight b8 by the way knight b8
and and
trading off like queen takes e4 because
i don't have anything
is is tremendous because you don't have
rook takes e4 in it you don't have to
take c3 anymore that's why it wasn't
working last time
that's a crazy crazy one king g2
king h8 instantly by magnus by the way
magnus needs to make moves i mean the
thing is knight v8 we saw because
originally version
pointed it out in a winning position but
then once you see the motif once you
you keep seeing it right he's not seeing
because the it is so strong on c6 moving
it to b8 is just like not a pattern that
you see in any tactics book
well the other problem with knight b
played it finally and magnus in shock
the board magnus didn't see it coming
and it's on the board and magnus is
leaned back he's got 14 seconds
to decide what the heck to do he can't
believe it
that's a quencher rook takes ba queen
takes e4 if you move the queen away
we are getting finally d8 on the
d8 okay queen d8 what's the follow up
here is it the queen c3 thing that uh
maurice has been pounding the table for
queen c3 allows knight f6 so i'm not
sure that does anything you
his knight will come back in the game uh
we're being told
takes a6 is the right move that looks
like a move you don't
feel like playing but why not just grab
the pawn he's at 132.
i bet you was calculating queen e4
yeah queenie for rook c8 i guess you
have to he came right back
he came back he put his knife back on c6
he didn't trust it
he didn't trust knight a6 well he didn't
get knight
yeah i guess and i guess he did like a
good move to me
he's burned more time though playing
this sequence
he's going to have to decide does he
want to go knight b8 and take but he's
worried about
bishop d5 maybe that's what it is knight
a6 what's bishop d5 he's taking it can
you take on d5
rook takes d5 c7
that's the key he's done there you go
bishop takes d5 he now has to find
the right sequence you said rook takes
d5 knight c7
your d2 is not hanging or something is
that is that all true
wait there's also rook d1 rook d1 wins
rook d1 he's played knight c7 though
he's played it and allowed
some kind of rook move that allows this
pin
on his queen bishop back to b7 but the
rook on e8 is
the rook on uh on e4 is pinned
tape right i mean you can go to e7 but
we're picking up so much
material guys 98 and indeed rookie 7 but
i guess the idea is
that after knight takes e7 bishop takes
f3 king takes f3 we're actually
up material there what about
the rook on c8 what about something like
this takes
this which he's done and now tonight's
back and rooks the eight is coming he's
winning
he's completely winning there's no hope
now because that knight on eight seven
is misplaced he's dropping a rook on
he'll pick that knight off
magnus with only nine seconds and magnus
that's the game
six seconds five magnus can see the game
is over he's just dropped his piece back
to f8 those tactics but um he's resigned
he
magnus has resigned he resigned the game
in view of
rook to c8 because yes there's no way
to avoid losing the knight on f8 and
then you're going to lose the rook on b7
as well and it's going to be
two rooks and two nights for a queen and
fabiano takes the lead
magnus now has to win the final game in
order to become the clutch chess
champion wow
this is what classic armageddon
13 000 and the lead
what a victory that those tactics guys
were outstanding at the end of the team
this is the thing i mean i said earlier
that um
bobby thought by many to be the best
calculator in
the world and now in even in rapid chess
a lot of times we don't see that but in
this game i mean
i i was i was just blown away there but
at the end
of everything that he was seeing he
takes an
instant 13k that brings his clutch bonus
jackpot up to 21 000
and most importantly he's now leapfrog
magnus
a win or a draw gives him the title
and 50k for firms that's clutch right
there
what he just did was absolute clutch
yeah sir that move rook the eight should
have been played into the queen d7 we
would think
that queen d7 long think put the queen
on
on the wrong square kept the game alive
kept too much
action in the position too much flavor
when especially
burning so much time on the clock if you
play queen d7 quickly
that would have been one thing but to
play it after so much
thought in this position after knights
the knight landed
actually on allowing the knight to get
to c6 it was a position right here
uh that you're showing this position
will be the one that magnus
will regret spending so much time on the
clock and then allowing
the dynamics in the position to be
maintained
but guys give it up to fabiano caruana
that
was absolutely boss in the clutch
he went back he found knight b8 finally
he took on a6
bravely knight c7 worked it all out
this is his very first lead of the match
talk about lead changes magnus has
always gone ahead and been caught
gone ahead and been caught gone ahead
yet again but thanks to this
three-pointer
he has now been overtaken and he has to
win or fabi is the champion
well magnus has got lots of motivation
guys
i mean this is this is gonna be a great
game i think magnus is going to
give fabi a run for his money literally
right here
um you know you can't get more
motivation than this and we know that
this world champion thrives on the
motivation
uh it's and it's good that he gets the
white pieces in this dramatic last game
right
total it's not like in armageddon where
you're also giving
giving black um so yeah to break it down
guys it's just what you would see from
an army getting game like a classic
armageddon game the only difference is
that
um bobby has the same amount of time as
magnets so usually when there's an
armageddon game to break a tie in a
tournament
the white player has more time
to compensate for the gravity of draws
at this level
right exactly whereas this is a straight
10-minute game
fabi wins the title with a draw or a win
magnus needs to win and all magnus had
to do was draw the last game and get
white in the last game
and say you're not beating me with i got
the white pieces
i'm going to just snuff you out instead
he's lost that game spent so much time
in that critical position
and now he has to win back to the wall
that's it he's got to do it and can he
deliver
in the clutch this guy is absolutely one
of the best players
ever and the challenge has been put to
him
win or go home that's it that's your
position
can he pull it off this will be
tremendous whatever happens will be
tremendous
certainly if he wins it would be epic
guys this is storybook you gotta love it
well it's not the same uh
fabiana cariwana from the 2018
world championship match who could not
handle
the rapid chess uh tie breaker at all
here he's going toe-to-toe with the
world champion and
uh the match has been great i mean then
fabi as you say
just wins at the clutch moments that he
had to and here's the standings
once again jen as we're getting all set
for
the twelfth and final game of the match
that's right well fabiano caruana with
eight and a half points
magnus carlson with six and a half um
but magnus can leapfrog with the win
these games are worth three points so
it's on the line in this game what do
you think he's going to play with the
white pieces
yeah he's played four in d4 it was crazy
the i the russian defense
is fabi's a a game defense right
they're back in their chairs by the way
magnus has been
getting advantages in these russian
games so i'm gonna go with e4
and i really think fabi made you know a
mouse slip
in the previous game he was black i
think he blundered a rook
mine slipped perhaps sometimes you know
half their
theory and they mix up the moves c4 on
the board we will not see
any of that and english for the money
yes you must appreciate
that move that nod from magnus carlsen
sure as he's gone back to we see another
king f2 will we see it again
uh game one of the match we saw the fred
rook e8 king whoa what
this is what you want to see crazy
dynamics
for the last game for the money e5
this is it now shark chess
i mean with all the money you know the
match online
uh 13 000 clutch money in this game
these guys are playing some wacko
chat wild five
b5 and he's playing knight d5 against e5
and my goodness this is just how do we
how do we deal with this bishop b7 i'm
i'm going to say if i was fabi's coach
i'd feel like why are we in this you
just need to draw
please and you're in this and if i'm
magnus's coach i'm like
yes we got something sharp something
wild i've got the two bishops i've got
space
i just need to get my king castled and
away we go
oh sorry i've got the majority on the
king side that f-pawn
f4 f5 f6 etc but favi doesn't look like
he's thought about anything so far well
magnus i just saw some kind of like
you know i've seen that from hikaru
ikaru usually looks up at the ceiling
like
as if he's accessing in this mind
a file and it seemed there for a moment
that
that that magnus was doing the same
thing this in other words what i'm
guessing is that this position is not a
surprise
that is to say for magnus that he's he's
prepped it b5 did not
uh surprise him okay but what has
surprised him because
now he is actually thinking about the
next move
he's not i suspect he thinks the move
bishop b7 is a mistake
i think his prep was primarily based on
this move and he was probably thinking
that
black should be putting like for example
let me just put a move on the board
that he was probably thinking that
black's bishop was going to go
onto this diagonal and when
oops excuse me i apologize for that and
when
he saw the move bishop b7 he's probably
thinking
uh i gotta have a refutation to this
don't i i like the move knight h3 that's
in my mind was really attractive
because i'm getting ready to castle
and maybe i've got ideas like queen b3
and knight g5 or bishop g5 and he did it
he did play knight h3 castles
d6 castles on the board as he's spying
knight g5 or bishop g5 maybe even a rook
b1 you
ah i'm not happy with fabby's position
if i'm fabi's coach
i'm i'm saying let's avoid this one
okay but hold on because now knight d7
has been played the d-pawn
uh the d-pawn is prepared to capture the
pawn on e5
the the key here really is going to be
control
white has to control black
and then you can say i'm just going to
do everything so
be a little careful your bishop move
let's say he moves the queen
to say queen c8
and now what takes
well you just just decided uh to go
after something very concrete in this
position
queen might have to move again are they
attacked i mean
what is this you can't play can't play
knight b6
i mean taking any responsibility i'm
just saying this
is wacko first of all your d-pawn is
gone so
your your e-pawn is gone so your d-pawn
is isolated rook to e1
by magnus i'm telling you this position
is about control
and if you cannot get the control you
want
black will have some some play here
black is perfectly developed meaning all
the pieces are out
not necessarily very well coordinated
but all his pieces are now
in the game white still has work to do
there's a knight on h3 there's a bishop
on c1 there's a rook still sitting on a1
yes you have space but it's just
and by the way that bishop on the long
diagonal b7 is going to keep your queen
honest as well
i don't think i mean i hear all your
pluses yes
i don't think it's that easy to
establish control of the position
as white so let's see if he can find
that that way and black has captured on
e5 i'm assuming a recapture
by magnus with d4 now
because i see c5 c4 as a potentially
annoying
thinking that maybe my bishop would be
well
with great reluctance to to to retreat
it by the way to
f1 it's not great on the f1 square
but i do i do see this move c5 c4 is
disturbing and he's played knight b6 by
the way
and c5 c4 by the way as you're pointing
out is the kind of move
that says you don't have control yet
right
you haven't figured out everything you
want to do this move c5 c4
dynamic actually i'm not a fan of the
knight on b6
myself uh this these knights working
this way
i need the knight on d5 to figure out
what it wants to do and queen e7
was played as he's trying to get his
rook to
the d8 square but bishop g5 will always
be a problem
hmm this this one i'm wearing an
uh-oh in our ear uh from our producer
and i don't know why he's making sounds
but he's gotten so good at chess after
so many years of art
yeah he's sitting next to verounakovia
he also has var he also has bar on his
side so
rocks queen to e7 does control
this diagonal uh the a the a3
f8 diagonal so that that's something but
a4 is always going to be a tickle
let's just say that it looks a4 with the
same idea but these blind interplays
work to d8 so
that would but still a four a five i
don't i just don't like that knight
there's a lot of potential here for for
white it seems like we have chances of
playing a4a5 but also
f4 f5 um i
i must say though that an uh oh for
foggy is a yay for magnus's fans right
so it's all relative here be careful
though jen because queen c5 check
queen c5 check is a move so
if you start pushing your f pawn too
soon
you expose this this king somewhat
although you do have knight f2
and just just watch out just watch out
the knight
i can't put my king to the light square
that easy eye there yeah
exactly so we got to be mindful of that
magnus now down to 6
21 two and a half minutes down
on the clock two and a half minutes down
at the moment it's been it's been a
theme
throughout this match today and even
yesterday that we're seeing magnus get
into
more time trouble than he did in the
quarterfinals match
or the semi-finals match and uh
kudos to to fabi
for putting the problems before the
world champion and making him forcing
him to think
the pressure is on the pressure's on
he's got to deliver and like you said
fabian has not let time be a factor
mainly in almost any game
when he's got to giddy up usually he's
he's made errors
remember that game where he played the
brilliant knight takes d4 allowing rook
takes g7 in that same game
he also blundered horribly by taking on
a5 with a pawn in time pressure
so he knows time matters when you're
playing this kind of chess
you've got to play reasonable moves
quickly that's the key and then
sooner or later you'll find some genius
moves as well since these are the two
best players on the planet
and as you've been talking about time
management magnus has not been listening
to you maureen
he has not moved he's looking for
something to do and that's 27.
and he's playing e6 on the board
and bobby leap forward what's the deal
if you take it what's what's the problem
yes we're going to go to that g5
knight g5 knight g5 and if work if work
f6
by the way i mean keep in mind that that
bishop on b3
lies in serious ambush okay
sorry uh jen you said rook f6 okay
yeah fabius captured it fabio said why
are you doing this
let me capture but you know f6 was a
possible move because then you keep the
knight out of g5
and f4 and we're being told that this
move
allowing the knight to get into g5 was
a big mistake f6 should have been played
and that way this knight does not gain
any activity the problem with this move
for black also forget the e pawn there's
also some queen c2 action
that's what i've been looking at c2 and
then if rook g6
we can play maybe um
let's see let's see how that looks can
we rookie six oh
what's wrong with just a straight circle
putting the queen on
26 rookie six but yeah so this wins
right now
oh thank you you're right rookie six is
crusher you can't take
rook takes because of queen eight seven
again and queen d3 queen d3 might not be
as good because you'd have queen c5
check and maybe f8 would be in a skate
square
well it was actually kind of funny
because i was thinking in this position
if i put my queen on d3 rook g6 i've got
knight h7
because i could play bishop
here but you're right that i missed rook
e6 rookie six is really a strong move
right sorry right here well we like to
go
with the queen on c2 so that you don't
have the c5 check right
this is crushing yeah this is nice and
he's played rook f6 it
is on the board e6 was a monster
bobby tiffany six and it looks like if
magnus finds
queen threatening on the long diagonal
the game
he'll have to play g6 he has no play
you're a move maurice we need c2 is on
the board
g6 is forced as the time that he spent
earlier
if you don't need to get into the end
game guys eating up three minutes
finding the sequence of e6 95 and queen
c2
is what we call time well spent
unbelievable as is your time watching
this broadcast hi guys
by the way i'm saying g6 is forced but
i'm worried about bishop to b2
after that well precisely i i had a
and i had an english against victor
korchnoy where
i was trying to trying to put my bishops
on these diagonals and eyeballing the
king
you're fabi's just gonna have to
sacrifice no
exchange he played rogue g6 he's played
he's missing
six months i missed it too it's over
if he plays rookie six it's over rookie
six queenie he has played rook g6
and rook e6 is a killer show them eight
let's show them eight yeah what's up
eight seven
check and now simple mate
f8 queen h8 is just mate that's just me
rookie six
magnus is just checking the line but
trust me he sees rookie six
rookie six is a body blow of tremendous
proportions you'll have to give away
your and now fabby has seen it too
because you i just look stressed
it's on the board what a bomb
magnus carlson with this e6 move bobby
didn't understand the point of e6 and he
took
he should have played about queen takes
and what about queen takes e6 how bad is
it up
really bad you end up with a rook and a
piece for the queen
and especially the fact that the king is
exposed
uh i i this is what bobby will have to
do
right i mean there's no other option
unfortunately for him
i don't think there's another option
either chen
what a disastrous showing take e6 was
beautiful
f6 had to be played keep the night out
that's what a match this is unbelievable
talk about a titanic duel
between worlds number one and world
number two
as they trade body blows in the clutch
game with
everything on the line 26 000
50 000 first 35 000 seconds
what a game i mean what a concept of e6
and there's got to be a movie in here
somewhere
e6 birthday c6 and now
normally after queen e6 96 rookie six
you might see positions where working at
piece
gives some compensation and some
fortress potential but with that king
wide open
and the two bishops and the codependent
knights on b6 and d5
no it's just gonna be hard to hold on to
everything i told you i hated that
knight on b6 as well and
at the end of this those knights aren't
going anywhere the bishop on b2
pieces just show up stream into the
position so easily
everything drops by the way c7 will be
hanging as well because there's a pin on
that knight on d5
that's going to be nasty so this is the
the current i mean he hasn't played
queen takes e6
quite yet yes but i mean what else i
guess you could do the same thing but
start with queen g5 does that make a
difference
i mean same principle queen g5 bishop g5
rookie six
he's finally captured regrettably and
he's go he's leaned back and looked
behind
he's devastated he's now his head in his
hand he's devastating he can't believe
this has happened
and magnus just coming through at the
moment
this capture on e6 he just didn't see
the point of knight g5 i mean
knight g5 was he just just decided i
couldn't let this pawn
live on e6 but he needed to and now he's
not even looking at the board fabi's
looking away
he must have been so thrilled
exhilarated after a big win
and now the feeling just of dejection as
you know you're in a lost position
somehow you have to fight and this is
just just awful position
totally bishop d2 queen c5
rook d1 all of these moves for white to
simply play themselves
for uh fabby he knows
that it's gone it it's really bad he
he needs help he needs he needs magnus
carlson to stumble
that unfortunately will not get
any uh help any assistance from the
clock
he will not get any assistance from the
clock as they are pretty much even right
now magnus at 340
plenty of time not down to the two
minutes of kind of craziness that he had
before
he just has to consolidate this position
a couple of moves we'll get the job done
what uh what a game what a match
bishop b2 i found that to be a very
aggressive move
uh i thought bishop d2 and put your
queen on c5 you're rook on d1
then you don't have to worry about
anything here magnus is basically saying
look
your rook is actually not even great on
e2
i'll just take this knight uh i'll play
queen f5 take the knight
and uh don't forget the c7 pawn is also
hanging
when the rook leaves that diagonal is
also open so
you're giving away everybody he just
played the move queen
f5 uh maurice so that he's he's prepping
bishop c2
and this is getting it's getting ugly
uh past ugly after rookie six
uglies asked ugly to lose you me
jen and a bunch of people could beat
fabi from this position
this one is over this is done magnus
carlsen
comes through yeah well looks like he
will bishop to c8 now
and a queen why can't a queen just march
in and look at fabia again
queen f7 you mean yeah queen f queen f7
threatens bishop
g7 mate and queen g7 minute yep
take your pick so you can't you can't
defend it with a rookie seven move
because there's the bishop g7
yep that's a nice pattern it is a nice
checkmate
magnus has instead played queen to h5
wow queen f sure what he's threatening
with that move
bishop c2 perhaps um you know a little
bit of a deja vu
rook h6 not allowed because it's not
allowed night of six is that also very
strange
i must say i mean after you you you see
queen f7 and
i mean your hand can't prevent your mind
from not
making that move queen
how do you not play queen f7 but this is
devastating as well of course
by the way um just for everybody out
there
yes you could have taken the knight how
embarrassing that might have been though
as a loser
sitting back now looking at this board
very upset for sure and yeah for sure
what to do it's just such an it would be
such an incredible career achievement
for him because he never hears the end
of what happened in the world
championship with
exactly such a great match and then
really going down in flames in the rapid
tie break but here it is an even faster
time control
he doesn't even know what to do actually
he's coming to grips with the beast
look at him look at him now i mean he's
coming to grips with the position
with the reality not the position but
the reality of this match
just out just just gone from his from
his hands he just had it
you see that frustration you know
you know the worst part is to go down in
a game like this
it's one thing to lose be outplayed have
a struggle
but to go down in a game like this where
you have no chance
you take on these 60 plays knight g5
queen c2 rookie 6 buy
three moves you're gone he's played so
well throughout and now
he's he's got to go down in this way
and he's trying to figure something out
to fight back but
it's just not enough he's now down a
pawn as well as that rook and bishop
and all of white's pieces remain
beautifully placed where's the trick
where is what i was looking for
like there's got to be a trick there
could be a trick
a trick alert i'm saying rookie 8 is not
rookie 1 is not a trick
rookie 1 doesn't do anything you just
take it and move your king to f2
and rook f1 he just plays king e2 so
that's
that's not a trick either and fabi knows
it
give magnus credit though e6 wow
liven up the position and uh yeah i mean
we can also like what you're saying
maurice
rookie one's not a threat so that means
that we can play bishop d4 and you know
then
after after check and we run it we run
to e2
we're mating you on the back rank or g7
right yep
that's that's just the end you have
there's nothing there there's no
construction
and by the way that knight is sitting on
b6 as i told you i
wasn't happy with that piece it has not
moved those
as you call them codependent knights
it's just
just not a setup you want i mean it's
kind of cool that in that final position
we're actually threatening
four checkmates in one 28 queen f8
bishop g7
and queen g7 bishop f8 on the board
unstoppable looking bishop g7 you can't
play rook g5 because if queen takes e8
this is resigns this is he can stop and
look
there's no attack there's no way to deal
with the threat you can't take on f8
he did check last chance
bishop f8 even prettier knights
but you got to give it to magnus he's a
clutch player
yeah well they were they vote with let's
say let's say they were both playing
clutch in this match i mean
knight b8 knight v8 it was was fobby's
money move and now
magnus's triple money move is bishop to
f8 and that's it
the job done that's it it's over magnus
carlson is victorious
and he just gave up
the sure sign came up right there oh
wow that i remembered that even
finally got to get that back in there
amazing comeback by him at the end
that was the first time fabi took the
lead in the match in what was just an
epic struggle
but magnus comes in in the end he's
got to be feeling thrilled right now and
just absolutely amazing he did win
the 50 000 prize a total of another 25k
in clutch bonus money and he is the
champ
of this tournament and of course he's
just the world champion as well
amazing amazing match guys this was
amazing
can i boldly state the obvious we we
couldn't ask
we could not have asked for more a more
exciting finish
a more exciting match and what a final
what a final i mean congratulations to
both players who really
absolutely who really did steal both of
our all of our hearts with their
incredible moves and their incredible
clutch victories and i believe we do
have our runner-up
fabiano caruana with us
fabiano caruana the number two player on
the planet bobby
that was an amazing match
congratulations i know
you must not be feeling great right now
we just want to congratulate you though
game 11 what a big win on your part
uh you must have felt like you had it
after you won that game
um bobby you with us he's speaking but
we're not hearing him
i'm sorry we're trying to get the audio
fabi we're not can you hear me what
one second bobby are you there
yeah can you hear me yes we can hear you
now go ahead
uh yeah i mean that was that was an
important game
i thought it was also quite a good game
and
after that i kind of believed in that i
didn't believe i would i would lose the
last game
but yeah something just went very wrong
um to be honest i didn't expect him to
repeat this so like after the first day
i
kind of just saw that uh that b5 is
supposed to be a decent move and i
thought i'd take it from there
um which was probably a bit too casual
um because i obviously misplayed it
and and it wasn't a very good final game
i i mean
i i was blundering everything i mean i'm
sure he he played the game well but
for my from my side it was just like i
wasn't there in the last
game um and like after e6 everything
started to fall apart
i'm wondering you didn't have to take
when you think you could have played f6
keeping his night out
did you did you feel that this just
wouldn't survive
no i i didn't realize how how critical
the position was
it only kind of became clear after after
his next move
that my position was really bad um
yeah i mean of course after e6 i should
have taken some time i was
playing too quickly and i didn't really
believe
in other moves i thought i should take
it and then we'll see about it
uh but it was probably an important
moment um i mean after f6 of course the
position is looks very unpleasant but
he doesn't have a very obvious next move
and if i get c5 and c4 and then maybe
maybe he'll become unclear so but yeah
it was just not not a good final game
for me
abby on a bright note um you won so many
great games against magnus in this match
which was your favorite
i i don't know um
to be honest i don't really remember
most of the games in the match at this
point i
the last game is always the freshest in
your mind and unfortunately
it wasn't a good one for me um i mean
the
game the previous game pretty good fabi
yeah that was probably a very good game
um
at least it felt like i was playing well
during it also the previous game
uh the previous white game which i won i
felt like i
um played well i i think that the match
was sort of divided into
uh into our good and bad games i think
that we had
very good moments and we usually won
those games and then we had very bad
moments
um uh
and yeah the mistakes were unfortunately
kind of costly
i mean especially losing the the game
before
the clutch games um the tenth game
i think that was also very unnecessary
because i
i had gotten over the worst of it and
and then um i i don't know i again
played carelessly once once it became
equal or
i don't even think i was i think i might
have been slightly better at some point
in that game
so yeah i was a bit careless at some
moments near the end of the match and it
cost me
this match fabi was such a heavyweight
battle
you came back not once not twice not
three times but four times
in the match and even took the lead is
this what you play for
this kind of struggle when you play
against fantastic players like magnus
um well i think that i i was in general
feeling optimistic during the match so
i didn't take the losses too hard and it
probably helped me
come back pretty much after every game i
lost i won the next one
so so yeah i guess i was in good mindset
unfortunately you know
you can't you can't have any real
weaknesses
when you're playing against magnus and
and the last game was was a very big
weakness
and he pounced on it so
just because you're fighting well
doesn't you have to keep fighting well
to the end
it's not enough to just do it you know a
few times but you have to keep
going until the match is over and and i
wasn't able to
you know just a last question for me
you have a reputation of not being
necessarily great at
quicker time controls but you have been
tremendous
throughout this entire match and not
just this one but before
your comeback against wesley i mean you
you just played
herculean chess do you feel like this
might
set the doubters to rest the haters
who think that maybe you don't play well
at quicker time controls
no i i don't think so i think that the
haters will
think what they what they will just
regardless of results
um and it doesn't really bother me i
mean
i have confidence in my own abilities so
i don't really care what other people
think
absolutely well we were honored to be
able to watch such a match
tremendous fight you showed amazing
hearts
worthy run there for sure could have had
it so close
we'll be thrilled to watch more of your
games fabi good luck in your future
tournaments
thank you
and what a performance by this young man
looking a little different right now as
of course his hairstyle is totally
different than this picture
but either fabi is a fantastic chess
player and
he did show in the last couple days
that's how good he is
with game 10 as well and he takes home
35 000 actually 56 000
including all that clutch money but the
big winner
world champion magnus carlson and the
clutch champion
is now with us magnus congratulations on
the victory
first of all amazing when he beat you in
game 11
what was your feeling right there
knowing that you had to win game 12.
to be fair i was i was fairly calm
i knew i knew i would have have more one
more chance and
the way game 11 had gone i've been
sort of reconciled with the fact that i
was probably going to lose that game
for a while so i really at that point i
just relished
the the challenge obviously i knew that
it would
would be very very hard but
at the same time neither of us were able
to to defend
difficult positions to be honest
throughout
throughout the match so i knew that if i
could put him under pressure
i um i would have very good chances
and obviously the way it went
was um was uh was a dream
since everything just worked out very
well and i didn't
uh um i didn't really have to you know
squeeze it out i just could go for
could go for the for the juggler
at an earlier point that was it
magnus this match featured you taking a
lead
him bouncing back you did it again he
came back again you did it again he came
back
and finally you hit him one more time in
game 10
and this time he took the lead now i
know you're a basketball fan but what
were you thinking about just this
competitive match
between two great players
yeah it was in terms of in terms of
basketball i guess
we were scoring on every every
possession right because we started out
with two draws and then the next
nine out of ten were were decisive
and there were no consecutive wins in
the whole match which is
just pretty pretty sick so yeah i was
really liking
both teams scoring on on every
possession uh
i don't know i felt like yesterday i was
i i felt like i was playing better and i
was unlucky not to
um
to to come out on top and but today i i
feel like
it really could have gone either way um
and i i mean i won the first game which
was okay but
the next four to be honest i think he
played a lot better than
than i did and i but fortunately i took
took the one chance that i had in the
final game and uh
yeah it feels feels pretty sweet
we saw at the end there you give the
klay thompson
finger shush i know you're a golden
state warrior fan how sweet did that
feel
uh well so i tried it once before as as
you all
very very much know uh and it didn't
it didn't work out and i've been
advocating
doing like um
doing the the church when you've um
when you got a good chance to win
because i feel like
when when you do it after you won you
don't actually
risk being humiliated and
why would you try and do this when when
you don't
like there should be some skin in the
game but this time i felt like
uh uh it was an uh appropriate
moment to do it but i i i will promise
next time i will do it when i have
something
something to lose and i feel like
uh at the very least i've given
uh my opponents more ammunition i'm
sorry i'm sure i'll see a lot of
shushing when when i lose games
not only by bayanishkiri you could have
done it after e6
yeah i know but that's what i what i did
last time and that
just had backfired so badly but i did
i did think after e6 fb
knight g5 i felt like unless i'm missing
something
huge i'm just winning uh so at that
point i did sort of prepare
the the celebration where
it reaches which is never a good thing
but fortunately the position is
is so winning at that point that i uh
that it's it's really hard to mess up
magnus the definition of this event is
performing in the clutch do you give
credence to that does
does that matter to you that when your
backs to the wall
when you have to deliver that's when
champions are shown champions
show what they're made of
i mean i don't agree with it entirely
but i also don't disagree
uh i think champions should
should show should show both they should
show dominance over time and also
dominance in in the critical in the
critical moment
and obviously this particular format
means that
performing at the critical moments you
know
that outshines every everything else
and i mean it raises it raises the
the stakes stakes a lot and
certainly makes it makes it very
exciting but i wouldn't necessarily say
that it's a
it's a hallmark of a champion to perform
um
to perform at the critical moments but
because it can be
it can be a little bit um it can be a
bit random but
i mean now that i won the tournament i
should just say that that's what it is
right but
honestly i think it's uh it's a very
interesting idea and i've enjoyed it
immensely but i i think you cannot
really
draw a conclusion either way um of
you know what makes a champion and so on
the question of consistency uh versus
performance in the critical moments well
you have shown both magnus
dominance over time that you're a clutch
player
congratulations on the victory indeed it
was a fantastic match
to watch and we look forward to your
future games
no thank you and um
uh i would just take issue with uh at
least in this
match or this tournament i didn't really
show dominance over time but
uh but i can't i'm talking about in
general in general
yeah no no sure but i came up with the
goods today and i i gotta say that
as as i know you've discussed uh as well
fabius made incredible
strides in in in rapid and blitz chess
and
i think uh well he's playing in the next
uh my new story tournament i think he's
he's
very much a force to be reckoned with
with and as i said earlier today
um he judging by the way
we played today he was as
a deserved winner as as i was and uh he
deserves credit for a
very good very good match well we
we appreciate that generosity i'm sure
he'll appreciate it
as well though he would have preferred
that you didn't play so well in the last
game
but but it's definitely a kind thought
as well good luck on your tour keep
doing great things keep being a great
leader
and everything that's happening in chess
it's it's really a thrill
for us older guys to watch you grow as a
champion and now begin to show
your leadership ability good luck in all
that you do
thank you and good luck to you to you
guys so well you also do
do thanks all the best magnus
all the best all the best
that's right and then magnus carlson 75
000 coming home with quite a lot of
change but
it's the title he did win this clutch
chess
international title um and you know goes
into
his next events with with this uh this
big boosting confidence and
so many interesting games to analyze as
well
right and jennifer let's just go down
our list of participants
and thank all of the players who gave it
their all
as this clutch chess event winds down
wow yes it's been quite a storied week
and a half
as we had all
of our players played so fantastically
maxine bachiro the grub
the frenchman just a pleasure to have in
the event
he didn't last long he did get
eliminated in the quarterfinals took
home
fifteen thousand dollars
and then we had lanier dominguez who was
far
improved from his american clutch chess
championship match against
fabiano but it still was not enough to
get the job done
he took home 15k but certainly improved
his
skills in this format along the way
and then we had this young man a huge
story of the event
jeffrey young taking a crack at the
biggest dog of them all
magnus carlsen and he got some blows in
and he can certainly feel good about
that as well as the 17 thousand dollars
that the 19 year old american pocketed
absolutely
jeffrey gets to say hey listen i lost to
the guy who was the champion
if you had given me somebody else i
would have gone deep into this
tournament
hey you said it yes exactly it sure
could have
could have been otherwise indeed as we
also have
alexander grishok and he came so close
to qualifying for those semi-finals
in a real epic match against the
lanaronion he ended
up with 19 000. i was robbed up by
choice i'm still
i'm sticking to that story he was rob
sasha
we know it and here is the man
that actually defeated and eliminated
grisha
in one of the better matches of the
entire tournament and that's saying
something because there was quite a lot
of awesome matches
lavon oronion ended up with 31 000
and he certainly warmed all of his parts
with his
you know insightful post-game interviews
absolutely and finally
we also have wesley so well that was a
crazy match against fabiano carolina he
beat him in a match a couple weeks ago
in the american clutch test he got ever
so close to facing victory again
against bobby but it wasn't to be and he
took home
37 000
and then we had fabiano caruana who had
incredible tournament nearly defeating
magnus carlson in a format that
many of us would have thought he was a
huge underdog in game 10
with a 5 second increment but he was
trading blows the hallway
and you know knowing how great he is at
classical chess it was just
beautiful to see
and our champion world champion
magnus carlson also the champion of
clutch chess
international and he really defined the
name of this event clutch chess
by winning in that final clutch game
three-pointer game leapfrogging over
fabiano carolina and taking home
75k what an incredible story it all was
and
guys it was a pleasure as always to be
calling all the action with both of you
and to our viewers again a big shout out
thank you so much for joining us
but let's really stop and say thank you
to the st louis chess club
yes thank you to the st louis chess club
thank you to parousian of cobian who
like me
had the foresight to pick world champion
magnus cryosan
to win the event we was wrong what if i
had it right through 11 games we had a
perfect
bar and i i die here seriously thank you
so much dravar of course to tom
marcus kevin um eric
everybody who made this possible big
shout out to tony rich and joy bray
the the executive director and man
general manager of the st louis chess
club and world chess hall of fame
it's just so great to work with this
team guys and the way they
adjusted to moving online has been
quite inspiring
truly it has been inspiring maurice
uh your final thoughts uh about
well your baby well i gotta say
first of all i agree with magnus it is
a champion is someone who is consistent
over time
as well as someone who delivers when
their back is to the wall
that is truly the mark of a champion and
uh this event though also the thing
about this event is it gets to
to prove or show who does perform
in the critical moments and i couldn't
have dreamt of a better match
one versus two at the end all the
stories that we saw throughout the whole
event
fabi's showing his heart his ability to
come back time and time again
magnus with his back to the wall proving
that indeed he is
a true champion this this couldn't have
been scripted
really any better than this this is
certainly very satisfying to me
personally
i do want to thank the st louis chess
club and
dr jeanne and rex singfield for
having something like this happen
allowing it to happen believing in the
concept
it's been fantastic guys and we've
called a lot of
events i got to say calling this with
the two of you this has been
absolutely one of my favorites so much
fun
just i i got a smile on my face this is
it
i agree maurice although it is kind of
fun to hang out once in a while
after the games but seriously it does
almost feel like we are in the same
place and by the way i did
get word that we broke viewership
records with this broadcast so
i do want to thank every single person
who watched this broadcast i hope you
also subscribed and followed to the
st louis test club and all the channels
so that you can find out about future
broadcasts as if you're new to chess
we're really happy to have you and if
you're just following the saint louis
chess club in our broadcast
you got a lot of archives to go through
absolutely
i'll just uh leave some final thoughts i
really like to say
thank you thank you very much to the
players
it's very important that after your
games that you join us on the broadcast
that you freely share your thoughts let
the viewers know you know your ups and
downs
and the cooperation that all the eight
players gave
magnus as well i just want to say thank
you
it was because of yourselves we get this
chance to showcase
these great champions your yourselves
and
uh your cooperation just really helped
so much so it just made the show
even that much more enjoyable so big big
big thanks to the players as well
and to leech us you know for uh being
our host
to tatev abrahamian for um being our
journalist and by the way she does
clutch
chess um after shows on the youtube
channel so yeah really you're
you're not going to be missing out on
content if you check out our channel
[Music]
amazing so until next time guys we'll
see you we'll see you all soon again
stay
stay posted keep your eyes peeled on
usjezcamps.com and
the st louis chess club on social media
on instagram and twitter because
there will be future announcements about
events
thank you all and have a good night good
night everyone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you